Hello everyone, hello, hello.
I am alive.
Happy New Year!
But welcome everyone to the first gaming stream of 2026 and
the first completed game of 2026.
Oh, God.
Sorry, I started choking on my saliva.
I got too excited about being alive, I guess.
God was like, are you sure?
Do you really want to bet on it?
I got too excited about that, Test the fate with that
statement Um Um But yes, welcome everyone Welcome No chat's
not dead I just forgot to add chat Like I literally I took
the nap Got you Right after Um Right after the Behind the
scenes Stream I literally Went up Uh Went Literally went out
Bed dad Walked him And it went back to sleep I took a nap I
was like I'm so tired I look at the time I was like I have
technically I have I have 40 minutes Oh my god I'm still
choking On my saliva I have 40 minutes Till my stream Surely
I can take a 30 minute nap And I'm still here I am I'm okay
I'm okay my saliva.
I am peak of physical health right now.
I am.
This is the body of a very healthy person.
Yeah, that's just the usual.
Let me put away.
I reheated my hibachi because I wanted a little food.
I won't put this away so I can actually start gaming.
but it give me a second let me rearrange my desk a little
bit oh happy new year everyone happy new year 2026 let's go
we're gonna finish haiti's two our first completed game of
the year it's gonna happen this for real this time guys i'm
not i'm not clickbaiting this time this time it's gonna
happen for real
Clickbait.
Joki won.
Nap.
Gotcha.
A thousand cracks on the wood.
Mr. Muffin Cains.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See?
I won the nap.
Gotcha, guys.
It can happen.
I told you.
It does work, guys.
It does work.
All right.
We'll put it.
What do you mean?
I've never clickbaited you guys ever in my life.
Well, yeah.
I want to talk about this.
I'm just sleeping a lot.
The last couple of days, because, like I said, I know I keep
saying a lot.
December was truly my hell month.
So my body is perpetually trying to catch up on sleep debt.
So I woke up in the morning.
I don't know.
I don't even remember this.
I woke up in the morning and then I wrote, I have an ideas
Discord server.
I put all my ideas in for stream ideas or like merch ideas
or anything like regarding content and stuff.
And then I woke up.
I wrote this down And then I went back to sleep And I don't
know what it means I don't know what this means What the
fuck does I'm like Is this like related to Uber Eats?
Was I hungry?
I mean I was hungry So I was like Was I so hungry that my
subconscious woke up And was like I want to order Uber Eats
Like I don't understand Understand this was in my idea
server past Doki.
What does this mean?
What the fuck does dragon eat me?
I couldn't I like literally when I woke up I spent like I
think like 15 to 20 minutes in bed Trying to figure out Like
decipher like like tracing my steps back being like what led
past Doki to write this down and I I couldn't figure it out
I was, like, looking at my history and my phone history and
everything.
Like, was I looking at something specifically?
And I don't know.
I don't know what this means.
And I still don't know.
I don't know if it was, like, Fast Turkey was trying to
think of, like, a fast food service or some shit.
But it doesn't make sense.
I can't figure out what exactly am I trying to do with,
like, Uber Eats or some shit.
I don't know.
It'll forever be an enigma.
It'll be forever a mystery, an unsolved hit mystery.
Doki lore.
Doki Raid, I am from the future.
Please, you have to remember, Dragon Eats.
Dragon Eats, what, Doki?
Dragon Eats, what?
Truly a mystery lost in time.
But yeah, I was hoping that maybe it'll trigger something if
I mention it to you guys, but I still don't know.
I'm reading all your comments as stone folk fucking know
what's up.
this means.
What brilliant idea did past Doki have?
And now I can't even make it into a reality because that's
all she wrote.
She didn't elaborate anything else.
She'll be like, obviously, if I write this present, Doki's
going to understand what she rereads this back.
But I don't.
You don't understand past Doki.
You should have been more specific.
I don't know will never make this a reality because of it.
We'll never know.
So unfortunately, this idea will be forever lost in time
because I have no fucking idea what past Doki wanted to do.
It's very unfortunate that we'll never be able to see this
amazing idea come to light whatever it could be whatever she
imagined envisioned in their head before she went back to
sleep thank you for the break thank you i hope you had a
great stream over there um maybe it's best for god and we'll
never know it could have been my next masterpiece but we'll
never know out that i'm live now real quick all right anyway
like i said today we're gonna finish it soon the first
completed game of 2026 let's go we have like four runs to do
and hopefully hopefully only four runs i pray to god it's
just gonna be four runs uh is it is one run is already like
that surface world the surface world is truly it truly it
should be hell Like, they should just swap hell in the
surface world.
Surface world is much worse than hell right now.
I hate...
I hate the last level.
The last level is actually so fucking hard.
The goddamn monsters.
I gotta warm...
The worst part is warming up.
We have to warm up live.
all right yeah hopefully i get four perfect runs in a row
all right here we go also i realize i forgot to mention this
but i do want to say thank you guys again for all the
support uh throughout the year for all 2025 because without
your support i wouldn't be able to do these amazing projects
too um because i forgot to mention this for the behind the
scenes things but you guys helped make it make it possible
just remember that it is a group effort uh without your
support the um we were able with your support we were able
to make doki la the reality back from the palace all right
here we go let's see hello my little froggy buddy soon all
this may finally be over not even doki understands what doki
is thinking my thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you doki truly is a mystery to all us don't even to the
donkeys we don't understand uh gotta collect the trash it's
earth day gotta collect the trash do we have anyone else
fishing with me i will talk to eris i'm warning you you
better cut this out trouble messing with chronos messing
with typhon messing everything up we're trying to save the
world you clearly did your job already bro you're not even
even helping much like how i often pick up after you hear
assembled accounts of doki's to crack this mystery well
you're not gonna and even if you do you'll look back on this
and wish things were no i do not i could have finished this
game like in 2025 this game would have been done in 2025
i feel self-conscious singing on olympus oh game is a little
low i can up it up a bit
uh let me know what's better yeah oh i wonder did the
weavings of the i have sound got here today father of all
monsters down the mountain last night he didn't see it
coming at least no not as such the weavings of the fates
tend not to be precise in their detail which i know can make
i haven't even met the fates yet i assume i meet them like
when i beat the game i'd like to think that i foretold it
because they're Like, kidnapped by my grandpa.
Oh, it was fine?
Guys, is it good or not?
Okay, wait.
I'll just put it back to what I usually do.
Past past Epidokie was fed up with Uber Eats messing her
orders.
So she said, fuck it.
We're making track who it eats now.
But last, she fell asleep.
Any investors want to make the next delivery service app?
Any investors, guys?
We need at least like one million dollars to get to get the
uh get us started startups ever like 70 of start-ups always
fail but don't worry we're the 30 i believe in us prophecy
another victory for the unseen transmutation i got it i need
another one i know what if i try historic persuade the
learned stage will put me in real the outcomes of You're
every night.
Oh, it's post-game.
Oh, it's 95%.
95% of startups fail.
But don't worry, we're at the 5%.
I just need a small, humble investment of a million dollars
to get started.
What's crazy is that that's actually very low for startups.
As an investment, that's actually pretty low if you think
about it.
Wait, is Tartar?
Tartarus?
Is Tartarus upstairs or downstairs?
Guys, we can be the next Uber Eats, guys.
That's what passed Doki wanted.
Oh, that's downstairs, and we don't need to...
We don't need to get it, then.
What if I need more shadow extraction?
Let me double check.
Fabric.
Okay.
There's a small loan, Dragos.
I'll definitely pay you guys back.
Just think.
Just think how rich we're all gonna be.
Don't worry, I won't Zuckerberg, you guys.
If anything, you guys get to be played by Andrew Garfield.
Isn't that an honor?
If it does happen?
I prevailed.
Oh, blast.
I was supposed to weave a yarn.
kept trying to crush me with his chin but i evaded and
clamber to the top of his head where i drove the sister
blades limb and oros into his brain oh quite gruesome at the
end there i like it my only criticism if i may is that i
haven't played this i haven't played had these two yet is it
good it is fun they had a lot of fun stuff i just hate the
aries edition i just think that one was the most annoying
thing they did and also i feel like there's just it's very
grinding I mean, it's roguelike, but to get the first
ending, you have to do like more clears than Hades 1.
But like...
But like, the surface boss is a lot harder than Hades.
Another shipment already.
Oh, nice.
Yay!
Always need psyche, though.
Uh, oh!
There's more stuff.
lures oh it's for their date embros i don't know what
embrosia is for about i'll buy it just for fun keep wait
there was a fish god sorry that's cute all right
yeah fuck eris blessing i don't i can't change my mind that
shit's stupid change my mind.
I fucking hate the bearish blessing bullshit.
Oh, I can't...
I actually have to wait till someone shows up.
Oh, the strongest nectar?
Oh, okay.
What can we do?
We're energized to go... Oh, wait!
We wanted this, right?
Why, this one would be good.
I would never settle the beef.
I'm a lifelong hater.
Yeah, I need three fabrics and ash.
I can buy that.
I think I need one more.
Like, I will hate her kids' kids, too.
Like, they might be, like, unrelated to whatever the fuck
conflict is going on between me and Ares, but fuck her kids,
too.
My hate is generational.
I tried.
How many do I need?
I need 30, right?
I have like zero ashes
And then There you go That should be enough
Power to change It'll be worth the way Bronos must believe
he has the upper hand Now that Olympus has the father Of all
monsters bearing down That'll be a lifeline For her too My
My children will also continue to hate I will spread the
I'll pass the hate down brady thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you maybe it was an idea for a membership
wallpaper dragon eating was a part of it controlled if he no
longer had olympus to contend with he would probably come
after chronos next it's like that infamous we can redirect
his uh it's probably a real thing like this um infamous
rivalry where like two families from two different hills
hated each other for like generational like for generations
and generations all because of like the I think it was like
they're like brothers or some shit and then like one fucked
over the other brother and then they they started like
hating each other from two sides of the hill yeah it was
like the hillbilly Romeo and Juliet yeah the hat fields and
McCoy's yeah yeah we're the yeah that's right we're the hat
fields and McCoy's oh I don't know Oh, you mean Team
Fortress 2 lore was based on the real actual people of the
Hatfields and Magu- You're related to them?
Aren't they, like, super inbred too?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, but I remember reading,
like, their history and they were, like, they were, like,
semi-inbred, weren't they?
Like, I don't get what it is.
Like, but they got better.
I know they got better.
You're right, but dad.
Literally, my wife is related to them, and I'm, of course,
super far back.
So she always says legally, she can't stream me as she hits
me with a nerve.
You can fix it.
I think it's fixed now, though.
I think it's fixed now.
It's been, like, like, decades.
They got better
Ex-factor they even the super chat.
Thank you.
Just like the lady gamer who max said Yeah, yeah, you really
fixed the gene pool if not his rage they start they stop
doing that I hope That our craft is never to be used for
destruction alone But no rule is immutable Our enemies'
strengths against them.
To rid us of them all.
Disintegration of monstrosity.
We got a new incantation.
Yeah, we should be.
I don't know.
This is our audio.
This has always been our audio.
You actually...
Well, apparently there's a lot of descendants of the
half-fields.
and macaws like they got i mean there was nothing to do back
there it was there was nothing i got surprised i'm surprised
that there's a lot of dragons here that have like um vague
relations to the half fields and macaws who even said that
to Sorry, buddy.
Wait, did he say anything after I said that?
Oh, my God.
No, he disappeared.
He never came back.
I'm trying to see in my chat if he ever said anything after
I said that.
Oh, he's crying.
There he is.
There you are.
See you.
I see you.
It's just a hi-hi-hi-ha.
Buddy and Bro is just the...
Why is he here?
Sweet old Tokilanda.
Let's see.
Wait, they're still feuding?
Wait, actually, I gotta...
Don't worry, we're still going.
Hatfields and McCoy's.
How?
How are they still fighting?
Now.
Today...
Oh, they're...
Yeah, their agenda despite the feud ending in a 2003 true
that is way too recent.
I know that's like 20 years ago, but like that's 2003 seems
way too recent for a feud to like have a truce right now
That's crazy Yeah, that's gonna be me and Aeris that's gonna
be how I tell it, yeah, it's generational hate.
Yeah, a foremost truce was signed in the 2003, officially
ending hostilities from the late 1800s.
Let's reinstate the feud.
Let's send in like, it's like in Fallout where they're like,
we will detonate the bomb ourselves.
We send in like a fake bomb.
is from the mccoy's
but there's a lot of like um lots of media based off that
parodies I mean Team Fortress 2 was literally parodying um
the hat the Hatfield and mccoy drama uh Feta thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you nah do a 40k in doctor
and aries descendants and searing as the ultimate evil and
fanatically do anything to atone for the sin of her
existence Oh my god That's crazy That's way too soon Like
it's a truce It's not like A truce means the feud can come
back Yeah anyone here in McCoy We'll send you in Like We'll
send We'll send a McCoy in To get rid of the truce
Let's see What does this mean
The wind Siding me up Yeah, that means like anything.
Oh, I mean I'm a warped profiteer I'll sell I'll make money
off of the off of it What did I use?
I forgot was a Zeus?
We needed Zeus thing, right?
I'll just go with Zeus.
What was this?
Okay, it was this I was trying to remember what was my Yeah,
assume mine was where Was the double binds, right?
No?
What was her?
Oh, wait, the double...
Oh, it was either double binds or the other one together.
Good old war economy.
I haven't earned it yet?
The three gifts of the veil to be bestowed to one deserving
of the title of Knight's Champion.
That's way too.
That's too much gotcha.
That's too much Gamba.
That's way too much Gamba.
It's just one room.
but we don't know what room it is to get some of that
eternal glory eternal glory if such a thing may come to
those who manage to achieve extraordinary feats so be it but
to chase glory as a goal onto itself that can't be right at
least it's never been our way but our ways can change
wouldn't you say we mustn't become mired in the olden ways
of doing things though i don't mean to pressure I get what's
yours is all.
Alright, here we go.
I think we can...
I think we can do this.
No need to fear it.
That's right.
We're gaming now.
We're in a game.
Alright, here we go.
We go up.
We just need one run.
Well, four runs.
But we can do this in four runs, guys.
all right so doki wants to reinstate the feud so in discord
between both families again you know who who's that like
that the goddess of discord thank you thank you guys look
it's a truce that means it can happen again it can start
whenever it's just a coincidence that when i mentioned it
maybe a feud started again thanks to your aid he's clearly
not the smartest one although Just a coincidence if the feud
restarts itself.
We want to attack.
Nice.
We got the Blitz right off the bat.
Whoa, that was fast.
That was actually really fast.
Yeah, early Blitz.
And it was a Blue Blitz too.
Oh.
Good.
Okay, started off strong.
I bet...
No, I don't have nectar.
Yeah, it'd be a shame if it was a little...
You know.
The sea spire stopped.
Their specials deal more damage, your cast inflicts hitch,
and immediately deals damage based on a flow and a binding
circle.
another other oh okay common less bonus damage
oh I have zero I have I have only a zero I have zero right
now zero commons but the more commons I have uh two?
should you do two for the hitch for the cast
oh it's the office no i have i have zero i have zero
non-common right now one or two guys
one okay we'll go with one all right let's go in heading in
back to the town where is hercules i haven't seen him in a
while uh oh hammer okay we're gonna get hammer we'll get
moon first actually the moon.
I got the power.
No, we're not free-willing this.
What?
Oh, there he is.
Excuse me, your parents are also gods and goddesses.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, I got...
This is not fair.
He's really kill-sitting.
It is not fair.
um excuse me i did most of the damage here that's fine
okay oh i need to remember to use my q i'm still warming up
right now okay a hundred dollars is a hundred dollars i'll
take those
oh can i use that oh hey nice thanks for the money uh i'll
grab the moon first You shine for me again tonight.
He's supposed to be a fair fighter.
He's literally Hercules.
He fights fair.
What happened to you, bro?
Ever since you...
Good.
Ever since you went to the surface world, bro.
Um, your hex makes everything else move slower.
Your hex launches.
Ugh.
All these are not the greatest.
Wait, that's not Hercules?
Uh, oh my god.
Have I not seen the A this entire time?
Wait, he's still half blood, right?
Oh, it was Hercules.
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna say, I was like, oh my god, mistake.
Sorry, you both...
At least...
Okay, he's still the same Hercules
All right, we'll grab three we'll grab them more He's still
the same guy you make it to the mountain yeah, I was gonna
say he has like the lion thing and everything Yeah, he's the
mightiest of men.
I was like who the fuck are they?
He's like Hercules other he's like Hercules evil twin
brother or some shit What do you mean typhon?
I'm surprised you're living don't have you helping out with
him instead of bashing a bunch of weaklings far from where
the real danger is the Olympians want to buy it some half
God stealing their glory I get the drudgery not the
important work thank them you never saw me oh bye there he
goes oh yeah cover your toes bro they're gonna stub your toe
there's a lot of sharp things on the ground Alright, get the
hammer.
Oh, I definitely...
I'm gonna change it to this side.
I feel like I'll hit more people if I do it this side.
Oh wait.
That's right!
Turn in the sheep!
Oh my god!
Wait, the big guy turned in the sheep too!
Nice.
Oh, I forgot.
I didn't see these guys.
Good.
Sheep time!
Oh my god!
Wait, I Curse.
Oh, wait.
This curse is actually so good.
Wait, I fucking destroy the house with my curse, too.
Okay.
My frog would do it for free.
Um, your dash strike hits the edge.
Your area, your specials are 25% faster.
Oh.
Oh, they're all good, chat.
All of them are actually really good.
I feel like three would be the best for my...
my build, right?
Alright.
I was gonna say, if you guys have the staff I have, I feel
like it'd be the best.
Just, what the fuck?
Where did the fire come from?
Oh shit, I forgot.
Ah, I could have changed it.
Oh well.
Wait, can I make them join my army?
Oh, they don't want to join my army.
Is there any extra rooms?
extra money oh it is nice there's extra room oh that was
fast for me oh grab the magic actually nice bonus room yeah
what happened to fordoki and all that shit uh where should
we get i feel i should get hp hp is always important There's
two, yeah, I'm gonna grab HP, it's two.
Two is more than one.
Good.
Come sheep!
That's right!
Yeah, health.
Oh, bonus room!
Okay, nice.
I got a lot of HP from that, too.
Okay.
Alright, what was that?
2 plus 1 tier?
Okay.
I guess I'll cry.
Any extra bonus room?
There's bonus money.
Yay!
Free money!
Free is free.
Uh, alright.
Alright, guys.
No more.
Oh, wait!
Birds!
See, I always put money in birds!
Yay!
Alright, we have three more.
What's the plan, guys?
We have Hef, Zeus, Magic, Hera, Hef again, and Fire Lady.
I always forget Fire Lady's name.
You're a bird?
Yeah, but there can only be one bird.
I have the Birdopoly.
Zeus?
Alright, we'll get Zeus.
More Zeus, more power.
I like the sound of that.
I demand more power!
Okay.
Your power is always nice.
I keep forgetting to use cast.
There's just so many buttons to be aware of.
Too many buttons.
Okay, nice.
Oh, your cast costs.
Lightning bolts.
Anisha counter.
I feel like one, right?
One would be the best.
There's some coffee in my...
No, I don't need coffee right now.
I'm okay.
I feel okay.
I might need to get water soon, though.
Oh, I could rarefy.
I'll rarefy at one.
Alright, your cast cost land boss three.
Okay, there you go.
I just got a mummer to use cast.
It's crazy.
I have... Oh, wait.
There's food here, too.
When I have to use, like, three...
Guys, I have to click three buttons.
There's so many buttons, guys.
Three buttons is a lot of buttons.
Okay, nice.
Become sheep.
Nice.
All right.
What was the next option?
Hera?
All right, we'll grab Hera.
All right, they'll slowly come over here, right?
Nice.
Become sheep!
That's fucking right.
Oh wait, nice.
They got cursed too.
Where is the...
Oh, they don't have houses.
Alright, we'll just destroy this and then grab the free
money.
Because I assume they'll be dead by then.
Yeah!
Yes, I accept this message.
Uh, oh, your Hitch Effects deal more in that...
Oh, in last plus five seconds.
Your cast moves created.
Fisher, that deal is when you're in your...
Oh, fuck.
Wait, born again.
Oh, but that's purple.
Fuck.
Born Gainer.
I feel like Born Gain, right?
ignore the Urpa.
But it's Urpa.
But guys, it's Urpa though.
Alright, let me go back.
No, it was more worth it.
No, you're right.
I guess you're right.
Alright, half last.
And it's convenient because you're next door.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot.
I'll make sure I don't accidentally touch fire because fire
bad.
I don't know if you guys know this, but fire is apparently
really bad.
I'm mining, mining.
I always have to learn the difficulties of fire.
Not even I get to do that much.
i mean i may have not considering what you did to get there
i mean it did sort of like isolated wasn't the whole led the
whole myth about heff was that he was so look this was what
they wrote okay they were like they were sort of like
ashamed of him but he was just so talented and inventing
they just isolated him into like this corner of the world so
they could just build stuff for the gods but then yeah okay
yes i didn't want to say But he was so ugly that the gods
just didn't want to look at him So they sort of like banish
him off of Olympus Yeah, wasn't that his story?
Yeah, I wasn't the one that said it Oh, now you give me the
stupid fucking Okay, okay, we've been trying to gamble for
this shit for so fucking long Does this mean uh yeah they
literally threw he was a baby too like like the baby cape
like i'm just gonna say it like not a lot of babies are born
ugly like did you know they're born like like super wrinkled
up because you know they're like filled with like you know
they're drinking it's a fluid baby like
all right all right but like if i get more magic does the hp
um does the hp like uh go up with it or no only current is
it only current okay oh yes as in it goes up with it or oh
it's retroactive okay it does okay we'll go with that then
such strength so maybe if maybe we can get more magic later
that's good that's
good to know we finally are able to gamma the magic It only
took us The next The next playthrough Asker It never showed
up in any of our other playthroughs
Alright Oh nice Oh we got more magic Okay we got both of
these Fuck okay wait 150 Guys quick maps What 250 Can I
afford 300 And Oh Oh, no, I can't afford everything.
No!
I'm 20.
Guys, I'm $20 short.
Can someone loan me $20?
I swear, I'll pay you guys back.
I...
May
no longer ferry souls into the underworld, but it's become
quite valuable to the ongoing war effort.
He's quite effective with that all of his.
All right.
Oh, we use plus five.
Genshastia and increases the less.
All right, which one?
Two or three?
Don't she won't repay.
How do you know that, guys?
I swear, I swear.
Here's an I owe you.
Oh my god, literally $20.
Okay, what do we get?
Magic or HP, chat?
Matt thank you for the super chat if everyone in chat
donates one dollar I'll be able to get $20 is that a quick
math and then I can buy both HP and magic
okay I guess I guess we'll get magic just so we can get HP
and magic don't quick I remember back when we first met, you
seemed enormous.
Much bigger than most any other foe I'd ever faced for now.
Damn!
Melanie!
You just think he's weak as shit.
But back when first we met, my sleeping schedule was to be a
leader of work.
I'm thinking suckers?
And I've still got my money for the bird.
Bro, they had a drug.
You get a super chat, they can take each other.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you He just wanted to sleep bro.
What's up?
She's just like bro you weak as fuck about everyone else
Bro, you're like a level you're like a level one crook I'll
have to take your word for it Anyways, just how big can he
be three square meals worth if I ever guess Been too long
since I had some monster meat
All right, I just got...
Can I turn him into sheep?
In Mune.
God damn it!
But doesn't he want to be a sheep, though?
Wouldn't he want to be a sheep?
God, what?
That hits me?
Should I turn him into sheep real quick?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
The last push step.
Okay, the last rock, too, apparently.
The last everything.
Yeah, wouldn't you want that?
Oh, my God.
The dash didn't work for me for some reason.
The dash ain't working for me.
Okay, nice.
I forgot the timing of the dash because there's, like, a
cooldown for it.
Sorry, thank you, this is for chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, he can even get a massage and everything.
If once this was a pasture and much livestock grazed and
roamed, now little evidence of this remains.
Wouldn't it be a dream for him to be turned into sheep?
He can finally live a peaceful sheep life.
He'll be one with his people.
Okay, I did lose like, majority of my HP, but it'll be okay.
Okay.
See?
Nice.
See, I told you guys.
Uh, restore plus 20% health.
Oh, I didn't see this.
Turns one random common boon.
Gains plus 30% while I have at least one.
Okay.
We'll grab the concave stone for more boons.
Let's go, Freenos.
Yeah.
All right.
On to the ship.
Ship time.
I would love to go on a cruise.
I've never been on a cruise.
I've been on a cruise once when I was like a kid.
To Alaska.
And I don't remember what happened.
I only remember the Alaska trip because my parents would
show photos.
Like, oh, remember the time you were in Alaska?
And I was like, I do not.
Then they'll be like, oh.
Oh, here's photos of it.
Uh, oh, wait, money.
Wait, can I unseal yet?
Breaking through.
I legitimately don't even remember what happened.
Okay.
Grab the ship.
This.
I do want to do a cruise one day in the future.
Yeah, I was like bored or some shit.
I don't fucking remember shit when I was four.
uh another appear and then appears most foes rain shots are
slower being dodged or two or three chat i mean minus 30
that's pretty good
i feel like i don't have enough money to do two do what like
with all the stuff they give me not the not the rain shots
early really adds up okay oh nice Oh my gosh, she gave it to
me so early, too.
This does not belong to you.
That's nice.
I got it so early as well.
I'll take those.
Oh my god, these already stole them.
Okay, I was gonna say, where the fuck is the last one?
Alright, $95.
I'll take those.
$95 is $95.
I won the 50, 50, and 50.
Okay.
Oh, hey, tree.
Alright.
And then sheep!
You shall become sheep now!
It's actually so convenient.
Oh, hey.
Mining, mining, mining.
Alright.
I can technically upgrade this, I believe.
Oh, sheep!
Nice.
Yeah, transform!
HP, I guess.
I mean, I guess.
More HP.
More magic and HP.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
That guy did so much damage.
Holy shit, I was not expecting it.
That's a big-ass sheep, though.
What the fuck?
It's done.
Alright, more HP.
Holy shit, that was a giant-ass sheep that I turned.
What the...
What the doesn't stop him?
Oh, it's because he's armored.
Oh my god, I didn't see the armor.
Oh my god, I also did not see there was more sheep down
there.
Okay, oh, we'll go with Zeus.
Yeah, I was like charging it up, and I was so confused.
Okay, sheep.
Okay, that's good.
That's good that I turned the big guys, too.
I actually really need that.
Oh, I cursed all the big guys.
That's really good for me.
Okay, the sheep move.
The sheep move is really helping the boss.
Wait, Duel?
He talked about his wife.
That he cheats on all the time.
Yay!
and i'm more than just your dear beloved wife aren't i yeah
she's the queen not the jewel authority oh you know that
marriage is gonna last guys oh you know you know this
marriage is going so well give up all your booms for each
okay how many okay okay this dude this boon oh no
What do I have?
That's Hera's.
Which one was?
Oh, it was this one, right?
Oh, it's Born Gain.
No, it was Born Gain.
And it was Born Gain and something else, right?
Yeah, I lose Born Gain, though.
I have two Hera boons.
Wait, yeah.
I don't think it's worth it.
No, I don't think so.
I mean, plus four.
I get plus eight.
though I do get plus a because I have two hairs yeah I'll
take three I'm gonna take three lightning from on high I
can't believe it they just showed up to talk about their
very wonderful lovely marriage that's very strong
Good to see you here, my lord.
Yeah.
Oh, I have enough.
Hear me on my authority.
Your taxes specials deal more damage for each.
Oh, I have 15%.
I have three right now.
Or deal more damage to armor.
Two or three.
Very strong.
Yeah, strong as You're very strong in the healthy
relationship.
All right, I'll get two.
Oh, nice.
But I got 150.
I still have...
Yeah, I still have this.
No!
I'm going away!
I'm actually...
I was like, oh, I still have a dump.
And I'm literally $1 away from magic.
I was like, oh, that's clearly enough.
I
All right Let's see what I get I can't I was one off I was
actually one off Cut above Are you serious?
It gives me a fucking sword one All right I mean I do use
All right I mean I do use it Are you fucking kidding me?
Do you have any Please share.
I literally need what guys if everyone if everyone in chat
donates a one dollar I'll be able I will be able to afford
one dollar to afford them I'm joking a really good reason
this is a joke guys You don't need a super chat I'm so sad I
just need one dollar
I should be allowed to like borrow money from him like I
don't understand I understand.
All right.
I'm champion.
And then broke you.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
See, it worked guys.
See?
I got one dollar.
It worked.
Oh my god.
Wait, what hit me?
I actually don't even know what fucking hit me.
Oh wait.
Oh now you're here.
You're very good.
I forgot like the casting one the
Jesus this is
oh my god okay there's so many things going on I grab the
ash sorry to interrupt hello we made it Pinky the dragon add
more fun 30 thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
very many bro thank you for the super chat thank you see
guys at work look i'm 159 guys it's working i caught a
glimpse of them as close as i dare to fight that huge storm
you could have squished you like a bug although i guess bugs
can't use magic to escape and bugs have wings very thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you to typhon size and
strength fortunately i'm quicker yeah that's how it works
it's like when in twitch on twitch when you do like twitch
plays comparison
to my inventions here I shouldn't even jest like that you
don't suppose they heard don't tell them I said anything
then thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh I
should be fine I have a lot of magic plus three
uh or do I do explosive oh yeah explosive too uh Probably
too.
I guess so because I use cast a lot All right, we'll do this
I do use cast a lot My I mean my entire build is cast to be
fair Okay, I can't get hurt is to be unscathed Okay We turn
them It was never it wasn't never gonna never mind I was
gonna say say if I turn them all into sheep I can't get hurt
and then I got hit twice oh my god at least I got an onion
something I was like don't worry guys I'll just turn them
all into sheep it's gonna work oh my god how did it send me
into the fire I didn't even move God, I did not move.
We got boom.
Fire hurts.
You guys know that fire hurts.
I have to, like, careful about this.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I got rid of these guys.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
I'm getting hit by it.
There's so much clutter in my face right now.
I'm like, I swear the the more runs I do, the Is it a thing
where they get stronger?
Oh.
Also, Katas.
One, two, or three.
Because, like, I have not seen these.
I think it's the first time I've seen those harpies.
I'm pretty sure.
Pushed to far enough.
I feel like I haven't really seen the harpies before.
oh my gosh okay quick maps 120 okay we should be able to
afford this this time i've calculated it and this time it
should work okay
but does that mean every time
three oh it doesn't work for my omega tag
okay so it builds up from there So it'll be like 10, 20, 30,
40, if I don't lose my armor.
Chat.
Oh, no.
It's just 10.
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
It just refreshed.
Two or three, guys.
I will have to use the...
It's just the normal ones.
I see more threes.
I'll go with three then.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Okay, I can't afford it, but it's nice that it's there.
I can do that.
Our guardians, guardians are like the room bosses, right?
I should get that.
Are they like the final bosses for each location?
All right.
I will grab that.
Yeah.
It's last for it.
What's the end go?
Okay.
I wouldn't get the HP.
The HP sounds nice right now.
Oh, plus 10 foes?
Okay.
I'm going to farm for the...
Oh, no.
I should farm for the end.
It's not the best.
I guess I'll do this then.
I'll do the plus 10.
okay um i might lose i might lose a death defiance maybe
hola toky amore mexico i i i ferrari blanco de frank ocean
muy bonita thank you for the super chat rick thank you thank
you i read that a little out of order but it was always like
the It was like what I could read.
I saw Ferrari.
I did it.
Tortilla.
That pronounced that.
It's tortilla, right?
No, tortilla.
Tortilla?
Now before I shoot you all to hell.
These senseless fights with you.
I cannot rightly say.
I appreciate them at all Never mind I love a more just the
mystical all love from Mexico Thank you for the super chat
Rick thank you thank you That's the spirit now how about we
stain that pale glow of hers and us sweet.
Thank you See drink it's filled for good measure
Oh my god, I'm so scared they back in turn hurt yes oh oh
it's okay she okay I'm just gonna it's okay I have this she
can't hurt me here okay but like obviously I was oh my god
oh god okay oh my Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Okay, I have another 400.
It's okay, I can hide behind this.
Okay, that was...
That was my cover.
Oh, it's okay, I have him.
I mean, I did have this.
Oh my god, that is...
She's scary.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, where did she go?
Where did she
go?
Oh, there she is.
Okay, that should hit her.
Yeah!
Oh my god, it like, okay, that, the plus 400 damage actually
goes so far.
Driftwood.
It actually came in so clutch.
The 400 damage.
Like, she didn't even summon any mods this time.
tab.
Nice shot.
We like, we like curved the bullet too.
We actually curved the bullet.
Nice.
Plus 90.
This is this is the eagle.
So we're gonna get this then.
We'll get knuckle bones.
It's eagle tab.
Nice.
Sheep.
Yeah, we cursed him.
There you go.
Uh, moon or...
Okay, moon.
Wait, let's talk here.
The majesty of Mount Olympus lies...
It's memory game now.
Underneath a heavy coat of snow, which masks the scars and
blemishes of a protracted siege.
Beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
Okay, I thought I was, like, in them right now.
Okay, nice.
What is he fighting?
Sheep!
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's good.
They turn, like, the one I really hate fighting.
That's actually really good.
That it turned these two.
Like, the worst ones.
With the goddamn snipers.
Nice.
I didn't actually have to deal with the snipers.
That's so good.
A trap is set.
Oh, my.
Oh!
Yeah, I got a crystal!
Let's go to crystal.
Um...
You remember if a blast deals 300?
I'm gonna try- I'm gonna- I'm gonna farm for this.
I'm gonna try for it.
Okay.
I'm gonna try for the end game.
Oh.
How much money?
199.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I didn't even see you.
No, it happened so fast.
Oh, yeah, it's only him.
How do you only have, like, one HP?
Bro, like, who fucking... Who fucked you up that fast?
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, my god.
Nice.
Okay.
Any money?
Uh...
Alright, Hera.
When you have at least two?
Oh!
I do have at least two.
Stronger for each.
Your damaging effects from a stronger spoon, give or you
have.
Yeah.
How many comments do I have?
I don't know.
One, two, three, four, five, six?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I guess I'll do that.
Yeah, I'm going to do three.
That was my boon.
Oh, my board game got rarefied.
Whoa!
What happened?
Why did it get super shiny?
Wait, what the fuck?
It just got super shiny there.
Alright.
Yeah, I booned a lot of stuff.
I don't even know what booned up.
Which one it effect.
I saw a lot of the names, and then I got confused.
I'll invoke it now.
Oh, shit!
Zeus, why didn't you kill him?
Okay, it's fine.
We have sheep.
We'll just curse them all.
Oh, that's so helpful, especially against these guys.
Oh, my God.
I got another sheep.
Thank God.
That's so helpful again.
for these guys.
Nice.
What the heck is my hammer?
Wait, where did it...
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
This cheap morph is actually so strong.
Oh.
That would be good for me.
Yeah, my hex is putting in a lot of work.
One, two, or three?
Three, right?
Two?
I'll do two.
Four.
Okay, I'll do two.
All right, talking time.
Time to party!
I didn't notice there was an entrance of nothing over here.
I don't know, Dio.
I'm ready to party.
Any idea why this mountain has been shaking ceaselessly?
Doubtless to the occasional dismay of your honored guests.
Yes, I do.
Sometimes the feasting gets a little rowdy.
Oh, so it was him.
With all the dancing and whatnot.
Uncle Besides, not the only Earthshaker on Olympus.
Nice.
No, Typhon has awakened.
The father of all monsters now threatens...
Is that a drinker excited to see us?
It's where he hides his second wine.
His special wine.
Yeah,
party till we die.
Let's go.
No worries.
Let's see here.
Your moves inflict hunger.
Oh, wait.
That's good.
I'm going to restore it.
We took damage.
Oh.
Wait, all of these are pretty good.
One or two or three.
Do you stack or omega or just grab HP?
Encounter is like each room, right?
Hmm.
Oh.
It's so hard to pick.
Alright, one or two guys.
you go?
I will say two would be very useful.
I'll go with two just because it'll be very useful for the
third, for the third place.
The third area, the last, I'm sorry, the last area is where
I'm scared the most.
I go with that.
I'm really afraid of the, like the last area.
I take the most damage in that area.
What's the...
I mean, we go magic.
We can get more HP.
Now, we'll get more boons.
I think we have enough magic.
Honestly.
Oh, God.
Wait, I can turn you into sheep?
Oh, my God.
It changes everything!
That actually changes everything!
Oh my god, I can turn him into sheep!
Wait, that's so broken!
Wait!
That's right, you're not a real boss.
In the name of Hades.
That's crazy!
I actually can turn him into a fucking sheep.
Um...
I guess we'll have to go to three.
All of these fucking suck.
Yeah, it's free damage.
Alright, nice.
Free magic.
Oh, hey.
Look at them stacking together.
That's nice.
Free stack.
Yeah, sheep tap.
Oh, my gosh.
I should have saved this.
have saved the sheep, though.
Honestly.
I don't need to save it.
Oh my god!
Look at all these sheep!
Yeah!
Excellent timing.
And more HP too.
That's a lot of sheep.
And we get Thina.
After much consideration, I admit the best plan that I have
for stopping Typhon at this point is to rely on you.
Yay!
I'm reliable.
would be most dire.
So you guys, I am reliable.
Lord Uncle Zeus alluded to some force that could potentially
defeat that monster, but bring great harm to Olympus in the
process.
Is that the alternative you mean?
It is.
My energies, as you can see, are focused on repelling our
enemy's forces here.
But it seems I shall also have to dissuade my father from
taking a catastrophic course.
If, but to buy you time, I'm counting on you.
Yay!
The whole world relies on me.
Let's go.
Oh, oh, Divine Dash!
Right?
That's the best one.
Great, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know me, Big Poe?
Which one?
One or three?
Or two?
Divine Dash?
Alright.
Save choice.
Yay!
Wait.
We'll go for shop because, like, I don't need nectar.
Yeah.
Her dialogue was literally a safe choice, guys.
I don't think that's...
Okay.
I'm like, do I need a slam in?
Oh, yeah, nice.
There's money.
Um, how much money do I have?
Oh, I can afford everything.
Buy this.
On my authority.
On.
I'm just gonna get one.
Uh, or two.
One or two.
two okay i'll get two then oh hey ermies i should go get
money after this because i don't have money anymore um if i
grab this i could get the palm this should help okay so um i
miscalculated yet again oh more dash more dash is really
good because i can deflect more Or, but I can, I have two
barriers.
Quick maps.
Guys, maybe my math was too quick, guys.
My math was too quick.
Quick maps.
Two or three, chat.
Map, not math.
My math's too quick.
Three?
Alright.
Little spring in my step.
Oh my god, look at all these statues.
I'm gonna get money because I'm broke right now.
And there's, because there's another shop and I do not have
money.
Oh, so that's why they're destroying the statues.
That makes sense.
Sheep!
That's right!
You too.
Oh my gosh.
There you go.
Is there any more?
Oh my god, there's a lot more.
I was like, guys, is there any more?
That should be the last one, right?
And then fucking everything shows up.
Yeah, money.
I'm gonna check if there's...
Oh, there was more.
More statues.
I didn't even know this.
that oh my god there's so many statues this is the last room
right 43 it's is it the last room or is it not the last room
it is all right maybe a four one thing maybe oh yeah mystery
bag trust what you wanted right
for seven seconds.
If it was near after your dash, you can cause a blast that
deals, your weapon deals more damage based.
I'm going to get two because I know.
Okay, oh, wait.
Oh, nine seconds.
Okay, but I might need two because those, I take a lot of
that.
Wait, really?
What?
Really?
It's actually one better than two?
Because I'm scared of the bird.
That's what I, yeah.
I'm scared of the bird.
fucking bird!
I'm gonna grab two because I know that bird!
No.
That, they send the bird out in the first three seconds and
that bird's gonna fucking beat the shit out of me.
I was, I'm gonna grab the bird.
That bird's gonna fucking beat me up and I'll grab magic so
I can get HP along the way.
No, you don't understand, that bird will fucking beat up,
beat the shit out of me.
Perhaps you're so called Master Kronos wants for you to fail
to suffer more than you already have that's right he seeks
vengeance on the god why do you follow this guy you're just
gonna get beat up by me over and over again i'm literally
the second bird i don't seek my master's forgiveness nor
assume his loyalty their alliances are born of shared goals
perhaps ideals it's really bird on bird violence across
purposes because they punished you for crimes you knowingly
committed what else could they have how is this 30 minutes.
What the fuck is wrong with the surface world?
I feel like I've speedrun held so fast.
Oh, see guys, I told you.
Look at, I told you.
Look, it doesn't do nothing for me.
Doesn't matter.
I told you guys.
I told you.
We had to invest.
Investment well made.
That bird was fucked up.
Okay, middle.
Oh my god, you're fucking kidding me.
Bird!
Oh no, the bird's coming.
my god okay it's okay i got sheep oh
my god this okay
oh my god are you fucking kidding me that hits me that hits
me too sheep oh my god he fucking just drifted away
the fact that he just slowly oh my god again middle bottom
middle bottom middle middle bottom middle it's bottom right
it's bottom then middle i can only go to three it's bottom
and then middle right okay bottom middle there we go i i
second doubted myself i knew it was that five second doubted
myself are you fucking kidding me oh my god i i deserve that
i literally went into that and that too okay
Oh my god.
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Let me send another one over.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
I lost a hundred, but it's okay.
But you cannot afford to give chase.
My strength shall return.
There you go.
Sheep is...
I'm gonna go...
I think sheep...
Sheep is actually so funky shot.
I gotta do sheep more.
I think sheep has been the sheep move and the the minion
move that's been the strongest so far
all right yeah grab humans oh i'm full hp nice all right
death defiance time time to go to true hell yeah sheep has
been mvp because every time i do sheep he um he takes like
or some shit the fortress of the gods reels against the
incomparable rage of typhon father of monsters giant of
storms who somehow lurks somewhere very nearby we'll find
him or the other way around yeah the heels are so good too
the heel i told you guys i the heels are oh my god not him
okay i could turn him in the sheep though thank god sheep
time that's right You live, oh my god, you live in my world!
That's so good.
That's actually so good for us.
Oh, I forgot they don't give me shit and cheap as hell.
These aliens don't have fucking shit.
These aliens are so cheap.
Oh my god, what am I looking at?
We're looking at this giant ass sheep right now.
Oh, this is hard.
Three palms or Hera.
Do we need any more?
I mean, we're pretty maxed out.
Hera or palms?
Hera?
What do we get from Hera that'll be good for us?
Try.
Oh my God!
No!
And he doesn't turn a sheep!
He doesn't turn his sheep!
Guys!
I think that's the worst.
What?
Okay!
Guys, I saw...
I dashed you guys saw that.
Okay.
That should hit him, right?
All right, that's fine.
I'm a little scared of him.
He doesn't turn to sheep.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, that sucks.
Oh, fuck.
Okay What the fuck is that range?
Okay Actually, what the fuck was that range?
Oh my god, he's anti-sheep.
Oh!
You're spreading these more damage when it does.
Creates a fissure.
Alright.
Two?
I am doing a lot of...
Okay, casting.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Yeah, I told that...
I'm glad I did the deal thing.
That thing was...
There's actually a lightsaber right now.
It's actually been, like, clutch.
Oh my god.
Why are you here?
Why?
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, we gotta go up.
Closer to the top.
Nice.
I can curse him right now.
That's really good for me.
Okay, nice.
Turned back just in time, too.
Alright, get in here.
Oh my god, each run is taking me almost two hours.
Oh, if I do moon beam, I can get my...
I can get the power up.
I don't need any heals anymore, but I can make a strong.
stronger as sheep.
More moon juice.
Oh god.
Okay, now I know how to fight him.
Sheep!
Oh my god, it doesn't.
Maybe I could Oh, I could turn the eye into sheep!
Guys!
The eyes can turn into sheep, guys!
Wait, that's actually so good.
I can actually turn...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I deserve that.
I can turn the eye and the sheep.
We're so back.
Monster Slay.
That's so clutch.
Should have stayed shut.
Alright.
I don't think I need this anymore.
Just because, like, I have so much HP.
I mean, maybe for the final boss?
Let's see.
X also charged up automatically.
Maybe I'll grab this.
And morph?
Um, I mean, it's one point.
I'll just grab it just for the sake of it.
And then...
Um...
I'll grab this.
And then...
Hmm...
I'll grab this.
So I can get overall damage.
I got the shot.
Nice.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Oh, we're at the end.
Okay.
How about a resupply?
I know.
Of course we don't get Deftified.
Fucking course.
He's still plenty mad.
Isn't there something your heck can do to make him maybe go
away for good?
Yeah.
I decide what.
How many times do I need you on Taifan?
Three, right?
But it may take some time.
Oh, great.
Can't do things quick if they don't take some time.
Well, then, don't let me keep you from your research.
See you later, M.
I'll buy the most expensive.
I mean, if I buy this, I get...
I mean, I could just buy hearts.
Um...
I'll buy the most...
I'll buy hearts the most expensive.
So...
Oh, wait.
25.
How much would this give me?
Yeah.
Um.
Yeah, I'll buy this so I can grab another one.
There we go.
And then, for my calculations, I cannot afford both of
these.
Okay.
Um.
Uh.
I can only afford.
I can afford armor and moon by moon yeah
is it worth it will make my hex more expensive is it worth
chat it's not worth right I might as well get these three
instead is it okay I'll grab it then it's worth right Okay.
Alright guys.
Or Heth?
Is there anything that Heth gives me that I would want?
No?
I'm like thinking.
I feel like...
I don't know if Heth can give me anything that's worth it.
It is?
Alright.
I accept this message.
Oh!
Yeah, I might as well get heavy metal.
Yeah.
I might as well fucking get that.
Oh, of course, I just get like plus $10.
I can totally afford it or something here.
Alright.
I got rushed for DPS.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
I get like a hundred something or some shit.
Hello.
Welcome back.
Okay, I'm gonna watch this.
I'm gonna take like so much damage.
in the beginning.
Yes.
Sheep!
Maybe he'll turn into sheep.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Sheep da!
Oh my god, what do you mean?
He's in mood.
I don't understand.
Okay.
It's bad.
Sheep dive.
Oh my.
Okay.
That's bad.
I'll take this.
Okay, I should actually do that.
That's good.
Sheep!
Yeah!
That's quite enough, Typhon.
Rick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thanks.
Don't worry.
I'm definitely pausing the game
Okay, there you go We are the palace keep them occupied Oh
god Okay It's time.
Oh my god.
Okay, I did not expect that Okay, I'm gonna wait until they
launch So this is how we have to the major It is how
monsters are, but yeah, yeah, they turn in the sheep.
That's right.
Sheep time.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
That's, oh my god, that was not fine.
I thought I was fine.
Oh my god, sheep.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding?
kidding me?
I can barely see shit.
Okay.
Oh, guys.
Did it!
We didn't use one single death defiance!
Oh, my.
I actually had a god build.
Thank you, brother.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
That was actually a god build that I had.
I did not use a single death defiance for that build.
crazy i wish i could just repeat i could just reuse it that
typhon oh my god the sheep guys the gods starts to relent
perhaps because its monstrous source is nowhere to be found
glory to the sheep at least for now oh two more two more for
typhon like chronos is fine i think typhon was just hell
typhon is just it's just his finally it's just the arena i
hate that the arena for it the fact that had the sheep made
the last arena so easy for me dawn i did tell zagrius
preparing guygaros may take a little while yeah that build
was really good the king and queen welcome back oh hey oh
she's here too how my lord husband scoffed when first i
brought forth and perhaps this deadly witch niece of his
raised from infancy to banquished time itself could also be
of benefit against the titan siege glad i won that out
herodia of course we reached agreement on that matter else
my good niece would not be here now though tell us menui
what news of a lasting solution to our predicament typhon
shows no interest in turning away maybe if you help out a
little i don't know maybe cool you know would be better than
two gods fighting type bot maybe three and maybe four ah man
i'm crazy for thinking that though i know it's crazy we got
honor the 1v1 right though we have not achieved those means
as yet you hear that soos the greatest inconveniences we
face may be resolved okay shot him with lightning what else
do you want from it oh no shoot him with a second lightning
a thunder he has more than one lightning it's not like he's
like one one per day
please hold out as long as possible you're so greedy dokey
one way or another i'll be back as soon as i can kronos may
have reawakened typhon but that same power could unravel him
May it be thus, we'd ask you take your time, my dear, but
there's no telling how much we can spare.
Nevertheless, tread carefully, and we shall be awaiting your
return.
Don't you men catch, shoot lightning?
We have a cool down.
Oh yeah, the refractory period, right?
He shot one lightning's got...
Come back soon.
God damn Zeus.
Oh, flower, it's truly you.
Forgive me, I... We must maintain decorum.
Oh, Damir!
Rather than within the dimness of a boon.
Lady Demeter, the owner is mine.
We're finally here!
Everyone's preoccupied contending with the siege, and it
couldn't have been easy for you to be here now.
That's why he comes back every hour.
I was furious to have missed you when you visited before,
and was not about to let that reoccur.
But you cannot stay, can you?
I have to go back downstairs and do it all over again.
Bro, each run takes, like, almost two hours.
Jesus Christ, I fought.
Alright, before we talk to Apollo, I'm going to get water.
I'm running out of water.
I'll be right back, guys.
With the weavings of the face.
The sun shall rise and dawn will break.
Our fated glory ours to take, though perils come to test our
will.
Our noble home is standing still, weathering all storms with
fire.
From highest peak to the deepest seas below.
We tend the weak so that mortal lives may grow.
Bleeding flowers in the springtime, Craning to feel the
morning light The sun shall rise and dawn will break Our
fated glories to take Though perils come to attest our
willful home Is standing still
enjoying his little his little concert guys and many thank
you the super chat thank you thank you you truly think it
will soon get blasted typhon well out of our way for good i
don't think it's possible change i think we got this if we
can rid ourselves of chronos then we should be able father
of all monsters too and i've not been training all my life
for this only to fail now i know she has been she never had
a childhood well remind me never to get on your bad side
sunshine you're ready to head home always good to see you
though i'd best get back to singing so that everyone stays
calm all right we have this i gotta go home now bye everyone
we're getting closer goodbye please stay safe
now yeah we're getting somewhere getting closer guys we're
getting closer and closer we're almost there two more runs
chat two more runs
all right prometheus two more typhons I don't care about
Kronos Kronos is fine it's just the surface world with you
Dora I didn't mean to upset you with talks of Titans when
last we spoke no true ending will take too long I don't
think I don't think we're strong enough for true ending
something about the name Prometheus oh what it meant
something to me huh but Prometheus was a imprisoned for eons
prior to this point yeah if you remember him how do you
remember him back I'd be ancient history but I hardly
remember yesterday don't know how come I'd remember
something from that long ago I mean she knows Prometheus
remember anything from men except except what oh yeah just a
feeling but it isn't great except what to victory The
prophecy concerning Typhon's reawakening.
What made you think it would never come to pass?
I thought the weavings of your sisters were always certain
to come true.
The fates are not always straightforward.
Their prophecies are represented visually, not written in
detail.
At least the major ones.
I thought my interpretation of Typhon's return was likely
misguided.
So the fates wove the image of some terrible monstrosity
climbing Olympus and the other one?
the gods were all desperately trying to fight back and you
thought it meant what well it wasn't that exactly though I
didn't take it quite as literally as I should have in
hindsight I thought it prophesied that the Olympians would
have to stand against some sort of existential threat well
you weren't wrong
when the fuck do I get my free nectar I built this bar
because I assume I get free shit Excuse me?
All I get are a bunch of free loaders.
All right.
It said it gave me free nectar.
Also, what can I give to you?
Oh, fishing?
Who do I fish with?
I'm not fishing with Aris.
They're saying you beat Typhon single-handedly last night.
One step closer to putting everything back to the community.
I am.
the community i did not beat typhon single-handedly but we
managed to defeat him yes though i don't think you need to
fear a return to normalcy anytime soon i know you're trying
to reassure me but i can't help the way i feel i ought to be
enjoying all this while it lasts the future might be boring
as dirt but right now things are okay what do you mean
things are okay people are dying things are not okay my
entire family is kidnapped what the do you mean things are
okay typhon does not belong in this world yeah
i don't think there's anything i want to find for right now
uh and choppy okay we now got the disintegration of wait are
you fucking okay
okay oh we have eight okay that's good all right oh wait one
more run one more run oh my god wait what is better than two
if you don't overcome such hardships to reach that one is
better than two the palace grounds were like nothing I've
ever beheld though everything was so vivid I scarce could
see at all oh that for an incantation oh hope is a lie oh my
god that you do not never mind do more
hope is a lie never have hope i'd hope for like nearly two
seconds and it was a mistake
how was the surface still warm and welcoming i reckon You're
to be commended for even setting foot up there.
It was dreadful.
The city of Afera is completely overrun.
And there's a blind cyclops making sure no one gets out.
Nah.
Well, that all sounds entirely unfortunate.
That blind cyclops must be Polyphemus.
My crew and I once had a bad run in with him.
He's still going on about eating people.
I mean, what else does he have to do?
night he is he's like oh okay that's pretty gross chad's
been gone for a while now which i've noticed i have not seen
her in a long time
what do i fish with anyway do i get anything for fishing
with people chad think i can raise my grasp oh wait why the
am i getting psyche what do I do involve my psyche.
That's the fuck.
Okay.
Guys, I think I grabbed too much psyche.
Wait, can I cancel my order?
Wait, I maxed it out.
Guys, I've been farming it all.
I farmed too much psyche.
Now I don't know what to do.
I didn't realize 30 was the fucking max.
Alright, now I have a thousand psyche because I accidentally
farm too much um what do i want okay location rewards i'll
alter that
no use all right get the minotaur
um what do i upgrade
i have enough to upgrade
I could save up
Or should I
Guys which one Excellence
Where is that Do I have excellence?
Oh My excellence might be good But I have no I don't Oh wait
I don't have excellence activated guys we can I don't have
Oh maybe make my Oh my charge could be faster Should we do
this that, the sorceress?
I can make it faster.
Yeah?
I see it now.
I could do it again.
Fuck it.
I see.
I'll max it out.
I'm not sure what I have.
I have...
I have three left.
Yeah.
Um...
I'm using it, right?
Okay, I have to be sure punchers is also nice um i'll save
okay may we converse settle a little ways of the young one
these shades are making claims you felt the father of all
monsters yep that's me however i'm the voice of reason and i
say come on typhon's recent defeat certainly wasn't my doing
alone commander we have olympus on our side and more Oh,
right.
Um, yeah, that's what I said.
Technically, it wasn't just you.
Hear that, disciples?
She had a bunch of those fancy boons and who only knows what
else?
Then you win the wager?
Damn right.
God, I'm so humble.
So humble.
Whichever way I choose, I can prevail.
But where to focus next?
That's me.
All right, up we go.
Run number two.
Hold on, everyone.
All right, here we go.
You are truly one of us, Malinui.
I saw how mightily you fought my own eyes.
Even in the face of Typhon's savagery, your father surely
would have been as proud as I.
All right.
You're special in Flix Blitz.
Special, right?
Oh, I could rarify it, too.
Can I do special, chat?
Yeah, I'm gonna rarify it.
Ooh!
Dancy!
Oh, I got chaos, too!
That's always good.
Nice.
I have chaos for it.
But I think we have fishing here.
Yeah, it's fishing time.
The hunt begins.
I just realized the last run, we didn't even get any chaos.
Let's go get chaos real quick.
Yeah, early chaos.
It's always nice.
The earth itself shuddered as though an object of very
substantial size held from considerable height.
That must have been the being you called Typhon.
You chew coffee tall.
That's me.
Not good.
Not like other gods.
I mean, after it's...
You're stunned.
Oh, that is so dangerous.
Oh, I have two or three.
I feel like three.
So I don't have to worry about magic for a while.
If I don't get born gain, I don't have to worry too much.
Just don't get take.
I feel like, I don't know.
Three.
and then just hope that I don't get like it's just for
precaution I don't get boring again all right my kids you
always see all right I just can't use charge right yeah I
can't use my charge moves oh my god there was money there
it's okay it was just five dollars it's fine wait there's no
moon oh my god I think they saw my moon running was like
never not again for her
Oh my god, they actually like The most outrageous bit of
hearsay Oh, Medea I think lately on the winds about what
ails the mountain of the gods You've been heading that way
What's going on?
Things are alright I think If the hearsay concerned an
ancient and enormous monster Everything's alright Assuming
the Titans legions don't achieve it first It's not hearsay
Oh my Then I know which monstrosity you mean and you intend
to challenge him and all the rest you're entirely mad
sorceress but so is the world over i mean you could help i
mean i don't have to do this by myself oh shit
oh i feel like two right two as above so below all right two
yeah i could get so much Yeah, and then!
And then we can gap, maybe Hemp will give us magic HP again.
Okay, and then we'll grab Hammer.
Oh my god, I can't...
The thing is, I can't charge it.
If we're lucky...
It's so weird not using my charge move after I've been using
charge for so long.
I'm trying so hard not to charge my moves up right now.
oh my god it feels so slow it really feels so slow i don't
know if i just don't have i think i just don't have enough
damage there's two projectiles your specials are 25 faster i
feel like i should use two
two or one chat two i have my misuse split side two or one
two works a bit okay i will do two
oh my god it hits me from all the way there really it's fine
that should have been like a free encounter honestly
want to make sure i didn't that should count as an encounter
yeah i know i forgot about the I'll grab HP.
I'll grab HP now just in case.
I'm just gonna activate this just because I don't have...
God, that was such a good build, man.
That was...
I had, like, everything I need, too.
That really was such a good build.
I'm so sad.
Whoa.
I'll get rid of these guys.
Oh my god, it takes fucking forever!
I know it doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna kill him just for the sake of it.
It's so slow.
God, I wish I had my sheep.
I missed the sheep.
Transform him.
Okay, more HP, that's fine.
I mean, more HP is always good.
God.
I missed what I had.
It truly was the best build that ever was.
Okay.
Guess I got more magic.
Oh.
All right.
Who do we have left?
We got three left.
We have.
Hermes, Heth, Zeus, Apollo.
Aphrodite.
I guess for a hef, right?
Pray for a good hef?
I'll go for a hef.
Maybe I'll get the magic gamba.
Okay.
It's just a house.
It should be fine.
I gotta grab the other house.
It's fine.
Jesus.
I'm so not using.
Just taking 20 years to kill one guy.
Let's have one more.
One more chaos.
Welcome to the fine city of Afera, witchy.
The most important thing to know is whatever happens to you
there.
I cannot be held liable.
I work weapons, not miracles.
So, man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't remember that.
Yes!
Oh my god, we got three.
I didn't even bother to read the other two.
other two were not as good.
I hope the other two was not as good.
I didn't even read it.
I was like, oh my god, there it is.
We actually got our gamba.
The gamba.
We're... I hope the god I didn't miss out on some good-ass
shit.
All right, Zeus, right?
We'll go for Zeus.
Okay, that should be... This should be the last encounter,
too.
Which is always good.
Okay, where's the last guy?
Oh my god, the goddamn house.
No affordable housing for you guys.
Jesus Christ.
You heard it.
Is my Oshi evil?
Oh, fuck.
Good now for you.
Nice, there you go.
Oh, I can finally charge my moves.
do i have lightning ball effects one or three yeah this is
uh against the hoa regulations oh it works with blitz okay
um this doesn't align with the hoa so we gotta we gotta We
gotta bulldoze your entire house down now Okay, I can
finally charge my fucking moves God, thank God That deal?
Oh my gosh, I hope I get the... I hope we bump in the deal
again He has the...
Wow, they actually die now That's crazy They're actually
dying
Okay Wait, we gotta destroy this house.
Oh, wait, we don't need to.
It's already down
Jesus Christ, oh my god
Yeah, they got through
Yeah, the building is not up to code Access you're getting
close to a breakthrough there with grants and typhoon and
whatnot.
I don't want to rush you in but this is me help myself
sometimes.
Alright.
Oh my god, even...
Wait, I can...
Wait.
Attack, special, and cast.
Okay, wait.
Oh, is it just...
Oh, never mind.
Wait, I could be even faster.
Wait.
I could be so fucking fast now.
It's all speed.
Speed for days.
Finished here.
Okay, let's grab...
You know, let's then go in.
We're actually speed for days now.
We're speeding legally.
150.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm so poor, though.
You're a trusted boatman, compared with having to drag our
boons all the way into the underworld.
Although, he probably prefers it there.
Oh, my...
Okay, wait, I don't think we need gain.
I'm not gonna lie.
I legitimately don't think we need gain though.
Like, we have so much.
I would be honest with you guys.
Yeah, I think we'll deal with one.
Like, I think we're fine in the mana.
Yes, you be.
But instead, you spit my eye.
Wait, you don't have an eye, though.
I have done no such.
I mean, we could still be friends.
Maybe you would.
Put yourself in my sandals.
What do you mean spin your eye?
You don't even have your eye anymore.
Yeah, what eye?
I don't like the way you're treating me.
I am gonna eat you.
Okay.
What?
What
the fuck hit me?
Nice try.
Okay.
Let's shake things up.
Okay, that's illegal.
Shut up, put it here.
Just because I have so much.
I think it's almost done anyway.
Oh my god!
That's fine.
Oh, yeah, there's a black sheep over there.
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, this is...
This is not looking...
I'm, like, literally getting hit by everything possible.
I don't know how he's doing it.
He's just standing there menacingly.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't know how he's doing it.
He's literally just standing there.
There we go.
Everything's okay.
Don't stand in my way.
We're fine.
Just 100 HP gone.
But we're fine.
She's just standing there.
Drink some water.
See, look at that.
It's like we didn't lose HP.
Conkief's done.
I mean, is there anything that should really would be good?
I know you conkief.
If it works, it works.
Don't need to change it.
Don't need to change anything if it's been working.
What's the...
What's the saying, guys?
If they broke, don't fix it.
On the outskirts of the city lies a makeshift to dock from
which a vessel may come through the channel across the land
toward the mountain of the gods.
Looks like I'll need a ride.
All right, time to go on the boat.
Boat time.
Okay, I definitely do not need to do that.
Okay.
Oh, I just need a casting.
We'll grab Ash.
Okay.
Okay, we'll grab this here.
There's the last guy.
Oh, there he is.
He's so tiny.
I couldn't see him.
one what yeah
I'm not very happy with my court what okay whoops it's okay
just a little head just a little damage okay nice got a
little oh my god I got stuck I got stuck but it's okay it's
okay I got stuck but It's okay.
Nothing to worry about.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I keep thinking I can dash like for the rest of my life.
Time for a tune up.
I need a moon.
I haven't got a moon yet.
I have three.
Huh?
Three?
I have three Earth.
Oh, but it's not for Omega though.
I guess one then, right?
Yeah, because it's not for the cast.
It's just for normal.
I just need the fucking moon.
Yeah, I'll go one then.
Oh, there you go.
I'm just like, oh, you need me?
Okay.
I mean, that's good that she listened, you know?
I'm glad she...
You know, I'm glad she cares.
Nice.
She the goat.
Thy now, that monster Typhon must remember the bitter taste
of defeat, yet he does not relent.
Thus he has left us with no choice but to pursue the means
of his annihilation, little star.
Behold my light.
Oh my god.
Again!
Sheep time!
Sheep is back!
Oh fuck okay, I don't think I could turn the tentacles into
sheep Okay, this guy is actually so annoying.
I don't like this guy for the boss, but
Okay All right, there we go What?
Does he turn into sheep?
Wait, he turns into sheep!
He turns into sheep!
Guys!
Good news!
Oh my god.
He turns in a sheep.
That's actually the best news I've heard.
How?
Okay, I have to, like, dodge everything there.
Oh my god, he fucking kidding me.
Oh my...
Sheep tag.
Oh, my God.
It truly is the luckiest day right now.
He, in fact, turns in a sheep.
Oh.
Good news, everyone.
Good news.
I accept this message.
Oh, hey.
Good job.
I'll miss you on more damage based on...
All right, one or three.
chat i'm actually gonna get like a magic thing though if i
get three three all right three
oh my god the sheep run to the next vessel the fucking oh my
god i if i knew the sheep was so strong at the beginning oh
my god okay it's already gone my armor's already gone it was
too good to be true i should have used i should have used
the sheep earlier
sheep oh my god i could have actually like made my run so
easy if i've only if i use the sheep
Oh yeah.
Yay tree!
Big damn!
How regrettable to know Prometheus rebels against the gods.
Surely he must see that his pursuit of vengeance shall not
bring him any peace.
Is there no reasoning with him?
He isn't much for talk, but then lately who is?
We end up clashing just beneath the summit.
Apparently he always knows who's going to be the victor.
even if it's me he does what he's cheating oh he's foreseen
his own defeat before can you imagine poppet to know of each
and every hill awaiting why would you keep fighting if you
know you're gonna lose keep your clean record all right oh
oh yeah i'm bower hacks guys
We Gamba in Yard of Gamba, bro isn't a sellout.
Bro, why does he just rig the match, you know?
Just like how Jake Paul earned, like, like what?
Six million dollars?
I think it was more.
Six million dollars per round.
Gamba time.
All right, what did I get?
Divinity and what?
Okay.
What else did I get?
What was my first one?
night
oh okay nice oh I'm like cast too wait that's good I'm out
mega shit alright goodbye
alright dig a tunnel in the middle they're like slowly come
over it's like guys give me a second guys dig a tunnel real
quick guys this is very important fuck this I'll turn you
into a sheep
Alright, uh...
More magic means...
More HP.
I'm greedy.
Oh, I should have saved my sheep, actually.
Maybe I should have saved my sheep.
I mean...
What the fuck?
He's still alive?
He's still alive.
Sheep time.
Wait, where are you?
Yeah.
God, you could hide from me?
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
Apparently, you can't.
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
Yes, you can hide from me.
Sheep.
Oh, that's a lot of sheep.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I'll grab my magic first.
Whoa.
Cool.
The other night, I thought I saw you launch yourself towards
the Olympus Summon.
Right into that awful storm.
I couldn't even get close.
What was it like up there?
Oh, it was awful.
I normally like rain, but not like that.
Typhon is drawn to the fortress of the gods, as it's the
last defense before the palace of Zeus, likely his real
goal.
So the gods keep knocking him down, but he keeps getting
back up, trying over and over to accomplish the same thing.
a battle of wills battle of wits would have been easier, I
guess alright with these oh, do I have attack wounds?
That's pretty early I feel like three, right?
Not, seven encounters is a lot of encounters, but I think
that's fine how many attack wounds do I even have?
Three is not worth it?
Five more five more Two or three?
Seven is a lot.
I guess.
Alright, I'll do two then.
Alright.
Wait, three?
Two or three, guys.
It's 50-50.
I don't have free will!
Two or three!
Two or three?
Again, but don't get...
Two!
Okay.
I got two.
Wait, what did it upgrade?
Bye.
I don't even know what it went up.
Wait, what did it...
I only had one attack bond.
Okay.
That's fine.
all right next vessel oh there it is yeah the only one with
numbers on it the front of the fleet guys i might have maybe
free will was a mistake
i mean another pride won't be so bad guys or three do i take
away more magic i have Let's see.
Oh, I only get one attack.
Oh, okay.
Two or three.
Or one.
I mean...
I'm crazy.
Oh, yay!
Two of you are crazy.
Enough said.
All right.
Palm or health chat.
Palmer health I got rewarded See I got rewarded for being
crazy
Bob Alright
1, 2, or 3 HP for 400 HP Imagine Alright, let's go Let's
fight Ares Alright, let's fight Ares This is a little hardy.
Just about everybody on Olympus giving you their best.
I do need a moon really badly.
The gods, they don't agree on much at all.
No, they do not.
Yet when the need arises, they can set their differences
aside.
Something to try with your own kin.
You know who really gets what's going on up there?
Did you know Nike is an actual god?
It's the god of war.
I didn't realize.
I thought Nike just invented it.
that word.
Not a god, but like a phaer's, like an incarnate.
You guys know that?
I was like, wait!
Oh my god, she actually shot me.
I can't do anything with the sheep, though.
Like, she's in me.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's why it's called Nikkei.
My mind.
My mind is blown.
I just realized I now know why it's called Nikkei.
God is a victory.
It just clicked in my head, chat.
It actually just clicked in my head.
What the?
I watched for it one time.
Oh, whoops.
There you go.
It just clicked on me.
I was like, oh my god.
Guys, I have officially ran out of magic.
Maybe I should...
I... Oh my god.
I think I should have got...
Guys, I think I should have got...
Um...
What?
oh i forgot i ran out of magic again okay oh
my god i don't have a lot right now there you go
fuck where does she go oh no no no no no no oh god okay are
you fucking kidding me
Okay What
Froggy see you strife I'm glad he protected me.
Oh my god lost the depth of violence Into the purse Oh my
god The element of strife has vanished yet her influence
remains as earth and sea alike remain embroiled in free does
it's not your fault listen to her he did grace freedom oh my
god she lost the depth of science oh i don't think this is
the run guys i think i fucked up my build i may or may not
have fucked up my build
we don't want to try the
set all right Oh, we gotta get with Hera's board gain.
Okay.
Oh, hey, no enemies.
That's nice.
Okay, we need magic.
We definitely need magic.
I want it to...
And we need a throw casting.
For sure.
Sheep!
Alright, I'm gonna go dig wild.
Oh, shit.
I thought that was it.
I didn't realize there were more.
What?
Okay, that's fine.
No, no, no.
No.
Don't let him get close to me.
Oh, my God.
No, you...
Is he still there?
Oh, my God.
As long as he's not still there.
Oh, I palm or bird, oh, sorry not brain, palm or magic,
chat.
I can gamble rooms.
Oh, yeah, I can gamble rooms.
I survived the bird.
Alter the room?
But which room do we alter?
Which one do you want bet on?
Well, how do I alter it?
Oh, here, alter this.
Oh.
Which room do you want to alter on, guys?
Which one do you want bet on?
Want bet on magic or palm?
You want better magic?
Gamba, Gamba, Gamba!
What else?
Yes, I don't think we won the Gamba.
Alright.
She...
Pumped up.
Oh!
We didn't gamble hard enough.
Yeah, this run has been very unlucky.
I don't really trust this run.
Okay, okay.
Excellent.
I'm not feeling very confident right now.
Oh, deal!
Yeah!
Party!
You really are just passing through.
Look at all these temptations in every form.
The liquid kind, the sumptuous kind.
But you're unmoved and undeterred.
Yeah!
Look, I would truly love to stay.
Enjoy a beverage and a bite.
Speak with all these doubtless interesting guests.
But I can't.
Don't you understand?
Your mountain is mountain.
It doesn't care.
We're not partying.
Look at all the guests.
Look at all the cities.
They're partying.
But I don't want to argue anymore.
I mean, it's just another form of fighting, yeah?
So you go do your thing and I'll do mine.
Yeah.
Our special is this eve.
Ah.
Congrats, power.
And each fog appears, making you stronger.
Three?
Oh, wait, yeah.
Because I do cast.
There's no war in Mount Olympus.
Yeah, he's just like, what are you talking about?
Everything is chill, bro.
All right, I guess we go get Poseidon.
Poseidon time.
Maybe we can get more gosh.
I'd like a word with Lord Hephaestus about you.
Jesus.
Hey, yeah.
Thank you for the- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you.
We had a great sheep!
He doesn't turn to sheep.
It's crazy.
It's like he's like not a thing or some shit.
I don't understand.
Why doesn't he turn in the sheep?
Oh!
Okay, it's It's just my armor.
It's like he's not real or some shit.
We need we actually need another We need are you fucking
kidding me that hits me?
That's actually crazy that that hits me.
Jesus Okay
But what if he does turn in his sheep I don't I don't know
Unless
As what if...
I'm just saying.
What if he does turn into sheep?
Maybe if I try hard enough, yeah.
Maybe he'll turn into an electric sheep.
You pick the wrong target.
Wait, do you?
Do you?
You talked about Zeus.
Who gave my absence?
Oh, never mind.
He just wanted to be like, yeah, my brother's Zeus, by the
way.
Oh, I'd wake a hint that knocks foes away.
Makes you briefly restore any...
What?
Blood gain?
Okay, we'll do one.
But what if we have more HP?
I feel like HP.
I feel like we get enough magic now.
We have Flood again.
So I think it should be fine.
Just because we have mana regen now.
Oh, no.
I'm just hoping my free will is working.
Okay.
Sheep!
Yes!
Yeah!
Sheep!
Okay, nice.
It's fine.
There you go.
Yes, yeah.
Oh, moon!
Fuck!
Oh, I feel like we need sheep, but...
Alright.
Moon or hammer?
This is very hard decision.
Oh, this is so hard.
Hammer time?
Oh, but...
We don't have any moon upgrades.
Okay, okay, hammer tap.
Ready?
Oh shit, wait, we got...
I gotta activate this.
I'm gonna activate it just for the sake of it.
Just in case.
All right.
Oh my god, oh my god, that's fun.
That's when.
All right.
deals oh you're gains power shot that this i feel like cross
catalyze them too yeah she was always good oh my god and
mood oh my okay there we go it's fine we actually got
blessed we actually got streamer streamer the that's
actually crazy i was like but i wanted mood and she was like
bet
that's actually crazy that we got we You got her.
I'm going to fish.
Oh, I see.
I imagine.
I was like, I'm going to go start fishing.
In the middle of this.
I'm just going to fucking, let's fish, guys.
Yay, fishing.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
He's fucking teasing.
All right.
Manifest your desire.
Oh, 300 plus 400 damage.
We're not going to make it, though.
I feel like we have to try and get that.
5% damage.
10%, 5%.
10%.
Last two seconds.
Okay, we got it at the bottom.
1, 2, 3, 4.
I'm going to aim for this.
Yeah, I'm going to aim for...
I'm going to aim for the bottom.
I just need another moon.
Do I need more ash?
I don't think I need more ash.
I might as well just get psyche.
Oh, there's no way I don't think we need more.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that did nothing.
Whoopsie!
I did not know what that did.
Okay, he's very slow.
walking up.
It's okay.
I have sheep!
Yeah!
Sheep!
There you go.
Nice.
And then...
I'm a little worried about this because I use my sheep
already.
So... And I'm stuck in the corner.
God!
Oh my god.
I'm stuck in the corner.
Oh my god!
Sheep!
okay this is our oh my god they all got sheep they all got
sheep this is possible okay we got it we actually got it
what did i get out of it oh hard nice everyone got sheep
that was actually slow so clutch wait is this the last one
the last area 43 is the last area right the sheep clutch I
think we should...
Is it... Oh, it is?
Okay.
Oh, it's...
Prometheus, dude.
I fucking hate fighting him.
I don't have a lot of money.
It's fine.
I'm by everything.
I have two.
I guess... Gamba?
There's not much to Gamba anymore.
more, but last minute Gamba?
Yeah.
I do have two.
I have two.
Okay.
I do have two.
Alright, let's get more HP.
HP is fine.
Um.
Yeah, it's too late for Gamba.
Especially the last area.
Um.
Mmm, which one for this?
Two for regen?
Alright, no grab armor.
Oh, fucking hell.
I don't know if I'm... I feel like I'm weak as hell right
now.
Although I'm back.
It's me!
Tell me, Titan.
Do you recall a mortal woman by the name of Dora?
A shade responded strangely when I mentioned you, but can't
seem to remember what you did.
First leave it be agents of change.
That old shades latent memories have more to do do with gods
and their deceptions than with anything i did elaborate tell
me what's happened yeah you keep blaming everything on the
gods as though all this is solely there she's my best friend
it can't be that bad i mean dora the exact dora the explorer
bombados dora failings vices and downfalls i am not to blame
nor is this dora you tell her I said that no no oh god oh
god I'm so sorry I'm only afraid of one thing and it's the
bird oh god okay we're fine where is she oh I'm so lost oh I
Middle, bottom, top, middle, bottom, top, top, top, okay,
I'm here.
Chief!
I know it's done.
He's immune?
Okay.
This fucking sucks.
Okay, maybe I should have saved my sheep for this.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay, that's a fucker.
Oh my god, he literally punched me.
He punched me!
36?
Okay, that's five.
That's five.
Alright.
Middle.
Top.
Okay, bottom.
Middle.
Oh!
Okay.
What's after bottom?
Guys, what's after bottom?
I can only remember three.
Top, top, middle.
No!
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
That was so scary.
Are you fucking kidding me?
me are you kidding me everything hit me oh my god
I know it's not doing anything but like I'll take those
damage oh I should have saved it I should have saved it I
really okay oh my god oh my god I'll fucking cars you
fucking bitch you ego you ego whore
please get closer
oh god
oh thank god oh I didn't lose the deptifiers thank god oh
okay here we go this was to be my future we did it enough of
his foresight by like five things at once there that was a
little awkward but it's okay we made it it's it's okay it's
okay we made it in the end we we made it in the end
okay we didn't have to use a deftify and thank god
all right off we go
That was so lucky, you two, when I did that dodge.
Alright.
Grab that $10.
$10 is $10.
Jesus Christ.
Sheep.
I'm just going to turn this guy to sheep real quick.
Alright.
A fucko.
Are you fucking... Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I don't need that armor.
All right.
Zeus or palms?
Yeah, pretty low on her.
I do.
I need to grab, like, food real quick.
Zeus?
All right, Zeus.
Oh, please.
Okay, these guys...
I don't know honestly maybe I could turn them into sheep
guys maybe it's a oh my god he already fucked me up yes
already sheep tap please no not you not you
oh no this is not good for me what oh my god I got stuck I
got stuck I actually got stuck that's so unlucky for me Oh
my god.
Please chill.
I got stuck.
I'm so sad.
I was so unlucky.
Oh my god.
I couldn't dash anywhere.
I got stuck in the fucking corner.
This fortress is your grave.
If there's one good thing about this war, it's that even our
most preserved family members have to rise up.
and make themselves known or just make themselves known in
the case of my good son if esther's here what is this duo
yeah another one of you find just there dad and right in
which he's a shot too just when i thought he couldn't
possibly stoop to my level he continues to surprise oh
okay i mean that should be good right is that good Oh,
they're meh.
Okay, I mean, I'll grab it.
There's nothing else I can grab.
The sound brood of storm-bringing Typhon crawl through the
growing cracks in the stonework of the fortress of...
Guys, I don't know if I'm going to make it, guys.
I'm very, very poor right now in HP.
Like, it's not looking so good.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what hit me.
I...
The worst part is like...
I don't even know what hit me there.
Was I next to an egg?
I couldn't even see it.
There's so many things happening to me.
Okay.
Okay, Moon.
I'm gonna grab Moon.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm going to grab moon.
I'm not going to...
Yeah, I'm going to go grab moon.
Yeah.
I need moon juice right now.
Wait, maybe I can turn him into a sheep.
Dude, can you go...
Can you get turned into sheep?
Oh!
Shit!
I forgot how fast he is, guys.
That is...
My bad.
I legitimately forgot how fast is that sheep guys he doesn't
turn into sheep that's crazy I can't believe he doesn't turn
into sheep what do you mean okay
that's fine okay okay
that's fine oh oh is he to do oh shit i didn't notice that
okay he's charging that's fine the charging ones are fine
sheep i know he doesn't actually work but like you know oh
he's stuck
okay all right
oh my god he's gonna go chompy chop isn't he
oh my god he fucking what the fuck yes oh my god the random
dash got him okay it's okay we got moon power just his day
moon power moon power oh nice we can grab both both of these
and our rest is just whatever
I'll do automatically charge.
Fuck it.
And this.
Yeah, I'm gonna grab the extra damage.
Oh.
Thank god.
I think I should...
We should be at the shop now.
Oh, shop tab.
Just need another...
food don't keep old typhon waiting get him okay we get food
that's actually really good for us i was like i need food
and then we got food okay grab food and then what should we
i guess we should get armor we can grab armor and the double
palm right i don't think we need more hp how much does even
give us yeah that's 25 Yeah.
I have enough.
Armor and a double.
All right.
One?
One.
Okay.
All right, let's go in.
I'm a little worried because...
I'm not that confident in my build.
I'm I don't know
Oh my god I fucking I almost messed that up Oh there you go
Okay Oh my god it's okay Sheep Oh Oh Guys I already lost all
that armor
already oh my god okay that's very unlucky that's crazy i've
already lost it up
are you fucking kidding me what is oh my god what's going on
like what the fuck is going on
okay Okay, that's fine Okay, it's fine Sheep Okay
Okay What?
That's stupid dog food Oh my god Here we go Young lady, I'll
take the stone here Okay
okay that's five it's not but like i'm coping right now it's
not but i'm heavily coping at the moment oh my god are you
it still hits me in the end okay
all right sheep i killed it all i think i didn't kill it all
i did not kill it all I, I did not, I guess I did not kill
him all.
It's fine.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's not looking so good for me.
not looking so good oh maybe
i'll hit him with a sheep
jesus christ oh this is my last one
guys oh
my god we did it that truly was the messiest run but we did
it we did it Oh, I won it left.
Oh, my God.
That was a little too close.
A little too close, guys.
I got it.
I like to make it exciting, you know?
Like, we've been fighting him so many times.
Just wanted to make it a little exciting, chat.
Oh, one more Typhon.
One more Typhon.
And we'd be free of the surface, bro Yeah, I'm just content
guys.
It's just content Typhon is not backing down though we shall
drive him back each night he deems to threaten us if that is
what it takes Yeah, I had to keep things super tense guys Or
we could probably destroy him along with this mountain and a
good portion of the surrounding countryside Although where
would we live thereafter We needn't wait that possibility at
all, Haram, my dear.
Best not to even speak of it.
Melinui assured us Typhon could be done.
One more run.
I've not intended to make promises on that account, not
Uncle.
Does Kratos get harder when his final run?
Or is it the same?
Do as you must, Melinui.
We shall be waiting to hear word of your success, and you
can count on all our blessings on the way.
Oh, thank God.
I can speak.
run kronos i just like my famous last words and then kronos
and i'm gonna die during kronos we're dealing with all this
light however i'm not used to yet we're not much used to it
here either for how dark it's been of late though let's get
you back before it drains you more take care now all right
half i go should typhon rise again oh smile oh no
It's hard to see him.
Return to shadow now.
What are you mean?
Closer to the incantations we require.
I never imagined I'd see the palace of Zeus with my own
eyes.
You know what?
It's fine.
I'm fine with Kronos only because I don't have to fucking
fight like Prometheus after this.
I hope you don't mind.
but I asked Prometheus himself about this old connection
that you feel he's cagey with his words but does seem to
remember you in turn kind of weird of you to do that
especially since it sounds like he's trying to kill your
family up there but thanks what do you say well he said he's
not to blame for mortal kinds failings and such and that
neither are you and asked I tell you so on his behalf oh
what does she do What was her sin?
I mean, we're best friends, so I feel like...
Like, clearly she didn't get punished.
It's Prometheus and me.
We're docking stomachaches, heartaches, taxation, lying,
cheating, you name it.
It's utter nonsense, but do you have any idea what he could
have meant?
Nope.
But since you're the one who's talking to him on the
regular, maybe you could ask.
Now that we're curious.
Alright.
Yeah, what does she do?
You're nice.
I know the Titan Prometheus.
I faced him on Olympus.
Little wonder he now fights against the gods, having met his
doom and lived.
Unlike the mortals he supposedly cares for so much.
Prometheus, I took no pleasure in his plight.
The gods certainly know how to make an example of someone.
Now he seeks vengeance.
pattern and the weavings of the fates now that you mention
it his knowledge of the future seems similar to that of your
sisters do you suppose he sided with Kronos because he knows
Kronos will we're gonna change the future change the world
there's no way that's why he joined Kronos oh he bet wrong
we're gonna rig the match little does he know we're rigging
that match we slipped we slip the fates like three million
dollars oh no that's too little for them we slip the fates
like a hundred million dollars one step closer i've had
these in my head for long enough oh my god thank fucking god
i can make it now oh my god yes yes all consumed within that
flood oh my god this is it
We got it!
It's here!
Alright.
We can make...
Oh, get an olive.
Fabric.
Wait, what's this?
Are you a fresh air?
Oh, I just need fabric?
I can grab that right now.
Alright.
Oh, moon dust.
Oh, I do not have enough for that.
Grab a nectar here, too.
Just for a sake.
Uh...
Just for the sake of it.
Boy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good luck on your supposed final run.
Don't give me sleep now.
All right, good night, boy.
Okay, there's final run on the surface, bro.
And then we'll be free from the surface.
Man, I might as well make this run.
Let's kill this because I can.
All right.
Sadly, I don't have olives.
You know the great Olympian defender, Talos?
One of the most ingenious inventions of Hephaestus and a
walking work of art.
Yet utterly unable to distinguish friend from foe.
That disappointing lack of judgment allegedly is not an
oversight.
Olympus deploys Talos where they want no one to tread, and
lately, their own mountain is that place.
Sometimes I think Olympus doesn't have the most cohesive
plan for their defense.
isn't Lady Athena herself supposed to be what plaid they
really rely on me for everything a little girl you know your
family goddess in matters of importance they all want
hundreds of years being immortal and their plan is to rely
on me costly to repair my father's spear Gai Gauras you have
planned Zagreus must have gotten access to it in his time as
I have now one final step then not quite I'm a little girl
compared to the fucking old-ass gods and she'll take every
precaution to ensure it shall have the intended result
Entropy is the last reagent we require for the dissolution
of time, but where am I supposed to find it?
I found no traces yet, even from typhon Where are you
supposed to create it if they live on the mountain, who
would hurt them?
Powerful enough force must be put entirely to rest Do you?
i believe so all right oh she's finally back i swear she's
been gone for so long walking typhon from his perch oh we
all heard you got a dozen family members all up there some
of them strong so what do they need you for they certainly
are capable but they're backed into a corner on olympus
please understand the mountain is rather tall it's like guys
guys here's the plan we live mountain there's no way
anyone's gonna fucking come here or just trying to appease
me the main reason you want is that monster yeah but for men
they see a mountain and they're gonna be like i want to
climb it what's that supposed to mean you'll see
all right typhon perhaps this night shall be your last oh
true showed to the world beyond the crossroads the altar of
ashes thrums with ancient power boundless men see a mountain
just think wood why do you climb the mountain because it's
there the bangle may we convert hey would you attest to my
disciples that i've taught you a great deal when it comes to
fighting typhon they've been getting a little unruly and
you'll be doing me a favor
but commander you've not told me anything about him ah i
know what this is you wish to see if i would stoop to
speaking falsehoods merely because i was asked um yeah yeah
yeah it was a test girl yeah come on young one would you
just do this for me here come on just just lie be okay one
little All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Finished business here.
All right.
Oh.
The Typhon is far from invincible, no matter how it seems.
When first you dared attack Olympus long ago, I personally
struck him down.
But now he does seem more resistance to my lightning than
before.
Oh, nice.
My special.
epic.
Alright, I guess we'll do specials, right?
One?
I feel like one, just so we can...
Okay, we definitely need some mana recharge somewhere
though.
Yeah.
Okay, Hermes...
Oh shit, I didn't... Nice.
All right, Burmese.
Who do you think can make it to the top of Mount Olympus
first, then?
You are old Typhon.
You've got a longer way to go, sure, but you're definitely
faster.
Yeah!
I want to be fast.
Oh.
Ooh.
I feel like...
Three, right?
More money?
I'll grab three.
Early game money time.
Grab this too.
Just squeeze on through.
I gotta squeeze as much money as possible.
Whoa.
Okay, we'll grab Moon.
Let's hope for heals or...
Out of heals or...
Uh, cheap.
Oh my god.
I hope I don't get unlucky here.
Judging by my luck.
Okay, we're gonna grab this.
All right.
Shades, I release you.
Be free!
Okay.
Long have I been the eye of night.
Watching you grow and train in secrecy.
Knowing that upon some evenings such as those- I have
parlors matter each in.
If they give it to me.
Oh.
Oh, fuck, they give me heal.
And morph!
Ah!
been like clutching it up for me though chat i feel like i
should stick with morph it has been clutching it yeah or oh
we have wait wait but we have uh oh come on oh they're all
good they're all good oh it's full moon really good oh it
has the most potential Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay.
We'll go with three.
Sheep.
Sheep hasn't disappointed me yet.
Oh, whoops.
Just fucking get slapped.
Just for fun.
Just for the sake of it.
Oh, let's transform you.
I mean, that's fine.
Let's get the early transformation out of there.
Believe in the sheep.
Who believes in me.
Okay, we'll grab hammer next.
Where is the hammer?
Where else can we go?
Okay, that's at the bottom.
Alright, nice.
Whoa!
Where are you going, girl?
yeah you shades are getting out of there get out of here
all right two or three chat
two oh if i've used minion though if i used minion the last
boss would have been so easy oh did i fuck up did i fuck up
guys I just thought about it.
But we sheep now.
But we sheep, okay.
Oh, I'm just thinking like, if we had got minion.
Let's have a look around.
I'm gonna grab HP.
HP is always good.
Oh yeah, Athena.
I mean, that's always good.
Okay
Yeah Yeah
Jesus Christ there's so many Yeah, I need matter regen
really badly
Why aren't you killing him then?
Oh, sorry Artemis.
Oh, I forgot to shoot this Artemis Athena I They both start
with A.
Olympus managed to take Typhon down.
I figure with your aid, probably Sister Selene's too.
I guess I wasn't needed up there actually.
I mean they're both like related to like fighting, hunting,
war, same thing.
But I don't think we've probably discouraged him.
Not yet at least, though I have a few ideas.
If your ideas involve an arrow in his eye, of which I hear
he has a lot, let me know.
Ah!
Oh cute.
After you dash removes me deal.
Oh!
Support fire!
One or three?
One?
Alright.
My strength is yours.
Oh yeah, nice.
Free room.
Oh, I should have went when I'm still...
I mean, sheep has, he has, the sheep has been with me
throughout the ride.
But I'm thinking like, if I had a minion, literally he could
just beat him up for me.
But it's too late.
Non-sheep believer.
How dare you die up the sheep?
All right, we have three left.
What else is here?
Alright, who do we want to get?
There's Poseidon.
We have Poseidon, Zeus, Apollo, Magic, and Aphrodite.
Alright, we'll try out Apollo.
We'll gamma for Apollo regen then.
Because we really need a regen right now.
It's pretty bad.
Are y'all dead?
Like, where are they?
Like, where are the fucking creatures?
Where's the last- oh there he is.
Oh I didn't even see that house.
That's why there were so many houses.
I was like wondering where they're coming- oh no I don't
have- oh this is bad.
I really need mana regen.
It couldn't have been easier for you being at the palace
here at the break of dawn.
Probably much more light than you're used to.
We're hardly used to either now thanks to all of Typhon's
storms.
all right oh yeah wait that's oh my god and it's epic too
very well yeah nice all right let's go over here all right
ending it off with zeus
oh god not the five oh my god this is actually so good for
me okay we're gonna oh Oh my god, that's a big ass house.
I just noticed how fucking huge that house is.
Oh god, it's all fire.
Oh god, get rid of the house.
It's against...
It's not up to code.
You know what?
Fuck that one, yeah.
That's right.
Now your sheep!
Oh!
I should get three.
i'm gonna get three because i'm always using cast oh and
there's free houses shamblers let's go oh i do have one more
i didn't even notice that
oh nice he is
oh i oh i forgot to i forgot to rarify it no i forgot
I was so excited!
I was so excited.
Oh wait, she stabbed.
Yeah, I turned them all into sheep.
I got too excited.
All right, we have Poseidon.
We have Poseidon, Aphrodite, Apollo, and Magic Left Chat.
I stay excited for free stuff and I miss the free stuff.
Apollo?
Alright, Apollo then.
Everyone, I see majority for Apollo.
Alright, I'll do Apollo.
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
What the fuck was that?
Associated, it's...
Well, I don't know what the fuck that was, but a sheep tab.
Oh.
Oh, wait, that's where they were coming from.
I was getting...
I'm trying to figure out.
That sheep tab.
Oh my god, the house turned into a sheep.
That's crazy.
That's wild.
The house turned into a...
Fucking sheep, guys.
Alright.
Oh, someone was throwing rocks?
More damage in a larger area?
Two?
Three?
I can't rarefied anything.
You can only do it for Zeus stuff.
It's between two and three.
Yeah, I only have Zeus rare five.
More mobility is always good?
Mmm, alright, we'll do mobility.
Ooh, we're so fucking fast.
Holy shit.
Yeah, we are super fucking fast.
Oh my god.
Alright, drink water.
In we go.
Oh, fishing time.
fishing fishy fish oh oh there's this that's so lucky
oh my god that's actually so lucky oh wait we should just
get one i can't even rarefied it's already epic yay it
doesn't matter but damage and million effects oh but then
there's three wait one or three Guys, three is massive.
One or three chat.
All right.
Be safe.
I rare five, three.
Is that better?
All right.
All right, yay!
I don't think I need to buy any more nectar.
All right, I have two.
Hello.
Don't you want your nappy tab?
Anyways.
to change stuff up a bit so why lights hard up here it could
be easier it won't be that town back there as you call it
would have been bustling with mortals now it's a festering
necropolis all thanks to the titan that is true yeah but
it's not but the sheep though but she yeah it's sheep's
alive but individuals like you you got too many ideals yeah
he's like so my sheep alive though haha that is true sheep
alive oh my god I was scared he's like who cares sheep alive
like who can blame him sheep alive all
right sheep sheep it's like wait a minute where did this
sheep come from that's right sheep Stop!
Chip!
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh god.
Yeah, that's right.
Get blinded.
Oh god.
That's right.
Get blinded!
Oh god.
What's with those?
Yeah!
Oh
Tired out Beepie
Marwa easy.
Oh my god.
I didn't even take any damage from that It was actually my
craziest run yet All right concave Oh, I didn't use the fat
I don't need his I'm nearly full HP.
He's like use the fat And I'm like, I'm full HP.
Good.
He's like, I did you see you drink that fountain?
Hydration is very important.
I say hi, Drayton, guys.
Fuck it.
Just for the sake of it.
He's blind.
What is he going to do now?
I'm going to pick some wood, though.
Hmm.
You know what?
I'll alter it.
Oh my god, okay, fine.
I was gonna say it.
I don't really need...
I should have just... I should have kept...
I actually should have just kept the...
So I just kept the heels.
I think the heels would have actually been clutch.
Not now.
Alright, that's fine.
him.
Yeah, I should have just went for the heals.
Alright,
uh...
I guess two?
Yeah, I'm gonna go with two.
Alright, we're actually gonna try and grab heals, though.
We don't have a lot of that going in.
We're a little bit poorer right now.
Okay.
Cheek!
Oh, it's just...
one yet goodbye oh i should have i should have gambled on
these no i could have gambled on those those might have been
a better gambler chat all right off we go oh my god i'm so
sad these were actually better
that's why i get blinded all right apollo or hef oh not hef
uh i keep forgetting her name heptis
estia apollo or hestia i don't know if you guys are trying
to correct me on her name or you want me to pick her all
right let me ask again apollo or hestia guys more apollo
because i don't I don't know if you're like trying to
correct me on her actual name.
Bessia is Bessia.
Both are good.
I see more Apollo.
You're calm.
Alright, Apollo.
I see more Apollo users.
Apollo fans in my chat.
What the fuck happened to me?
It's okay, I have sheep.
If all else fails, I do have sheep.
Oh, hey, Nesh, he's here too.
Since I got- get all the NPCs.
Yay!
Ah, the NPCs!
Oh my god, did- okay, that didn't hit me.
What's new?
Olympus, I accept this message.
Uh, oh.
I don't think I have the- I don't know.
Let me cast one.
Oh,
this is a debate.
Oh, they were pretty good.
I'll do it.
One, I guess.
Okay.
Thanks.
Okay, I mean, that works, I guess.
What was it?
your foes oh okay there you go i was like i i guess oh my
god forgot to give him a gift again his final moments wanted
to put myself through them again and again yeah that doesn't
help i was like i wouldn't have expected to icarus you were
young and you made a mistake what's the use torturing
yourself for it for all eternity yeah i thought you wanted
to learn to fly to prove yourself to your father come on
nelly i'm never going to prove myself to him but something
happened as i kept trying to use my wings i started to like
him who does it that is pretty cool you look so in your
element up there i just haven't been invented yet if i could
make you whole again perhaps some night we'd learn to fly
together i still want to feel what it's like you have no
idea how much i wanted that to oh wait guys okay not gonna
laugh with me dude look cute together.
Bro, I think he's in.
Bro, she's like, Melanie was like, you fly together.
I don't know if he's taking the hint though.
Bro, bro, she's into him.
I need three.
I feel like seven encounters is worth the gamba.
we're gonna lose that really quick two would be really fun
all right oh there's nothing else to do here what the fuck
oh what's the time one you cannot hide from us what wait
what the wait can i morph him into sheep oh my god i can oh
my god i could turn you into sheep Sheep!
Oh my god!
I was like, wait, but what if I turn you into a sheep?
He was like, I am a morpher.
And I'm like, bet?
That's right.
Uno reversaled it.
The morpher has become the morphe.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
What I learned is that I could turn this into sheep.
The sheep master.
that's crazy sheep oh my god two sheep wait two sheep oh my
god oh wait i can have two sheep
holy shit okay that one was a little too crazy
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Really?
That hits me?
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, but one more sheep.
One last sheep for the ride.
Come on, let's you have two sheep?
How many ships have fallen in that mall?
I did take a lot of damage.
I really need health though.
It was my least HP run.
Uh...
Also, but uses...
Uh, maybe...
I don't have anything on my cast though.
Hmm, yeah, one...
Hmm...
I'll do one because I don't The only issue is I hate I can't
see shit with the red cast
Yeah I hate the red I can barely see where my shit is
I'll do a three I'll find him Maybe I'll get a better cast I
just can't see shit I want an NPC I'll do a three Oh, wait.
Have I gifted her a gift yet, guys?
Does anyone remember?
I don't remember.
How do I check?
I wonder if there's a way to check.
Does anyone remember?
How do I check if I gifted shit?
There's monsters, familiars.
Is it this?
Under others?
Where the fuck is others?
The rest?
Oh, here we go.
How do I know if I...
Oh, I'm not seeing it?
Oh, I don't...
Okay, we'll gift her then.
Madam Cersei, I'm grateful that we had a chance to meet
again after all this time.
meant a lot and i wanted to give you this small token in
return nectar oh thank you little miss i've made attempts to
brew my own but never get it right though why don't you take
this in oh yeah never gifted her yet nice reached out yeah
oh it's a picky it's a little picky crystal come to you
little miss living on my little aisle i must have been the
last to learn calamity had spread all from the heavens to
beneath the earth and chronos is responsible for all of it
time apparently wishes to ruin everything eventually though
we are not about to let him have his way we'll drive his
forces from olympus and unseat him from my father's throne
oh we immortals and our warring ways what example do we set
for mortal kind But I know certain battles must be fought
and I remain committed to our Lady Hecate.
Yeah.
I guess two.
Two times.
What do I get?
Swift Runner and Wadeward Sun.
What is that?
Swift Runner.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I'm even faster now.
Gamba time!
I don't know, that gambit was pretty nice.
I'm even faster.
Meow!
Speed.
I'm so fucked.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
It's fine.
Yeah, shoot time.
Yeah, my favorites.
There's a lot of people on this ship.
I did not expect that.
Which way now?
Oh, these are all pretty bad.
I'll grab the bones.
Since I need it.
And I'll grab this too.
Alright, sheep time.
Yeah!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Bro, I hate that.
I don't see them anywhere.
Just the last guy hello oh wait he's dead i thought there
was like one more guy or some shit uh health we really need
health oh god that's so bad i was i was actually risking
that i was like surely it'll be fine right i'll take this
guy right here i'll turn him into sheep again that's right
eternal sheep for Oh, hey.
What's this do?
Oh, there's a shop!
Um, but who I'll grab this.
Okay.
Pay extra to get in now?
Uh...
It's fine.
We'll wait.
I can wait.
Actually...
Yeah, I can wait.
That's fine.
I need to save my money.
I have the shop right after.
Yeah, there's no reason to.
I really have to shop here.
I'm gonna buy the moon first.
All right, let's see here.
Oh, inflicts a curse.
I'm gonna go down.
Maybe down?
Oh, there's no damage to boss.
Oh, my God.
This is a pretty bad...
Oh, I should have went for the minions.
I should have went for the minions!
I'll do this.
Alright.
The stars align.
The shrines of Lord Hermes that I've seen around the
surface.
I noticed they take off rings of gold as well.
I take it the two of you are back in business then.
Okay.
Then may business be good.
All right.
Shield or Aphrodite chat.
Has the black flagship sails closer to the shore?
The princess of the dead knows well that whatsoever strife
she has experienced thus far this night is about to get
worse.
Oh no.
That sounds pretty bad.
Shield or Aphrodite.
I can only afford one.
God, I've never been this fast before.
Aphrodite?
Alright.
You're both in there has such an ugly job having to smuggle
little blessings such as these into the worst of places.
But we make it worth his while, don't you worry about that?
I guess?
Oh.
Hmm.
Mmm.
I don't want or three.
We don't have anything on our cast.
Weak is nice.
Alright.
We don't have anything on the cast, too.
So...
Yeah.
Alright.
I might lose a Death Defying Shield, maybe.
Because I don't have a lot of HP.
And I don't have the damage to...
Because she's immune.
to the quirk of the sheep.
I can attest he and that bird have come to terms.
Come on, have pity on me, Aris.
I have to deal with fire and feathers here and again at the
top of Olympus.
That is a pretty good appeal, babe.
But unfortunately for you, I don't have heart.
Don't call me babe.
How fucking dare you.
What the fuck?
How is that?
I mean...
Okay.
Okay, next fight.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Wait, where is she?
It's fine.
I got sheep, though.
I got sheep.
Oh shit!
Here!
Alright, that's good.
It's okay.
It's alright, we're here.
Okay, that's fine, I guess.
Maybe I could do something with the sheep?
What the fuck?
Where is she?
There you go.
I'll stay here.
All right, that's five.
That's what the...
That's what she is for?
Nope.
Oh my god, come on.
Okay, it's five.
Okay, I just thought maybe...
I don't know.
Like, why did you hit her?
Okay.
okay that's not cool are you fucking kidding me okay there
you go oh we're fire I did get burned a little bit just just
a little burn oh I didn't have to use my depth of fines at
least.
I feel very low HP though.
I'm not very comfortable with that.
I don't know.
I feel like I use... Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Uh... Nah.
Okay, we'll grab this.
Oh.
Proceed.
I don't know.
After having 340 HP, everything feels very low to me.
Everything.
It just feels very low after that.
Like, I don't...
I can't go back, guys.
It was so nice.
Oh, hey.
We got the bomb upgrades, too.
Oh, yeah, Moon.
I was too used to being a tank.
There we go.
Use that.
Let's turn you into a sheep real fast and then
There you go.
Oh shit.
There's more of you guys.
It's okay.
There's more of sheep
There you go No, no, no, no, no, no get away from me Oh my
god.
Oh my god, Eddie called in more people Oh, God, that's so
messed up.
That's actually so messed up.
God!
He's here.
I mean, I don't know what else to get here.
Which is better.
Fuck, I'll just grab the blast.
Like, it's here anyway.
Oh, and there's Hammer.
Nice.
Alright.
There you go.
That's actually very convenient for me.
If I do it again, though.
Sheep again!
That's right!
Acceptable.
Alright.
Oh!
For my charge, that's really good, right?
Or plus 30 power.
One or two.
Or...
Yeah, it says it works with Omega.
It does.
Two?
Alright.
I'm grateful.
Oh, we have Chaos.
Is it worth doing Chaos?
I don't know.
Okay.
You guys think it's worth doing chaos?
This late?
I'm worried.
Yeah, this feels way too late.
It's so risky.
Room check?
We're at 37.
We have six encounters to do.
Huh.
Alright, we'll see what it gives us.
It is kind of risky.
Okay.
Hmm...
All right, let's do it.
Gamba time!
Gamba Gamba!
Oh, and there's extra money.
I'll pick that up real quick.
I am familiar with what you recently achieved despite
Typhon's comparative indifference size and strength.
How interesting are the smallest meanings of how often
proved to be superior?
Is my conception of strength incorrect?
Hmm...
I don't want to use my free will.
For super DPS?
That is true.
I will get a lot of DPS, though.
All right.
one super dps tab oh yeah i get to fish something yet stirs
within that murky deep
why is there fish here what the fuck is that matty what the
fuck why do you have fish here chaos okay i just have to
make sure oh i should have just oh i got so greedy I should
have just let them fight.
Wait, wait, this is fine.
Watch.
Because it's sheep time!
They can't hit me if it's just sheep time!
If it's always sheep time, they can't hurt me.
Oh, God.
It's always sheep time, guys.
It's always sheep time.
Sheep time will save us.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, hey, my delivery's here.
Oh, hey.
Oh!
What'd you get two?
Right?
The duo.
My M plus 25?
Okay, um...
Yeah, I should be able to, right?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's a lot of
people.
people though there is a lot though i am very concerned that
there is a lot of them it's okay nice all right i proved
myself this time health we got health uh apollo we should
grab apollo uh yeah apollo oh is it free apollo oh hey free
apollo In the name of Hades.
Oh, yeah, free Apollo.
Oh!
Inflix days as well.
It inspects...
Wait, two!
Supernova!
Wait, one or two, chat!
Oh, wait, I need to fight for chaos.
Oh, fuck!
You're right.
Oh, shit.
One is Erpel.
Oh, okay.
But Erpel, though.
Oh.
Wait, this is bad.
I'm at 40.
This is bad.
This...
Oh.
Okay.
I guess more Apollo.
This is...
The room was no lot...
Oh, we did not want a free room.
Oh, the gamble was a little risky.
Okay.
You have sheep.
You'll be fine.
Apollo or Aphrodite chat.
Oh, God.
This is so bad.
Okay.
Oh, please be the dragon.
Yes, it's the dragon!
Nice!
That's actually so good for us.
Because dragon is sheep!
Okay.
Dragon is sheep!
Sheep tab!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, we get a cast expand.
Cast expand, though.
Okay, we just have to hope to guide that the next one is is
also an encounter.
We just gotta...
I am very scared right now, guys.
I am very scared.
Alright, nice.
Jesus, okay, I better get...
Athena might be... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh, this is very bad, everyone.
Okay, there you go.
I was gonna say, she better show up here.
There's a lot of people.
Oh, she did.
I had a feeling because there was way too many people coming
in.
Uh...
Give me...
One or two.
I don't think I should invest in three only because It's not
gonna be good for endgame.
Yeah.
One?
All right, I'll go one.
I see one person said one.
I was like, you're right, one.
Have I gifted her yet?
Oh, I don't have anything to gift you anyway.
I can't even gift.
A clever ploy for Kronos to set such a thing on us.
Keeping us occupied while he plots his next move.
Whether clever or reckless, I'm not yet convinced.
Kronos is counting on Typhon turning all his violence
against Olympus, but after that, I'm actually getting the
craziest luck I feel like I'm fucking bumping into everyone
Perhaps Kronos means to seal the monster away once we are no
longer a threat at any rate.
We don't intend to let any such outcome transpire All right
Oh
Oh, wait divine dash nice That's actually what we needed
Okay.
Oh my god, thank god.
Alright.
Time for, uh, palm tab.
Okay.
That's good, that's good.
We actually made it.
Guys, we actually made it.
That chest is so good for us.
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank actual, thank god, moment right there.
Got worried.
Yeah!
Oh my god, okay, that's fine.
Sheep.
Okay, one last sheep for the ride.
Goodness.
More sheep.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Just took hold.
Finally got the shield, too.
Oh, thank God.
I don't even remember what I did it for.
What's the prize?
Oh, attacks.
It makes my attack stronger.
Yeah, one, two, or three, chat.
Three?
All right.
This is the last room, right?
Yeah, it is.
So, shop tab.
Oh.
I can afford everything.
I have five.
Oh, I have five.
Oh, wait.
I can hold cash.
JK I'm holding cast This is always This is really good for
me I can aim it too Yeah I'm gonna get the second one chat
Oh but I have five though Plus two power per fire boom
Okay fine I trust you yes I'm by everything All right.
Gold coins.
I had five fire bombs.
All right, here we go.
My master does not realize what shall become of him once all
is said and done.
Do you?
How abhorrent to try and steal away one's immortality.
I've truly heard it all.
I'm not bumped into Hef at all this run.
I think like Hef is like banished from this one.
what shall become of him really talk about dora your
father's father you share some of his ancient lineage and
his obsession with the inevitable come get what you desire
then but one outcome awaits as you continue down this path
what is it what are you awkward are you kidding me Oh my
god, that's stupid goddamn fucking up Are you fucking oh Oh
my god, he's a idiot Okay, middle top middle middle top
middle
Cheap I know it does nothing, but you know it's just for the
fun of it sheep oh my god where is he i don't know where he
is oh my god oh my god where is he where is he okay top
middle middle top middle top middle Middle.
Top.
Oh my god.
Guys!
I did it!
Are you proud of me?
It's a miracle!
Okay.
I'll grab that extra fucking damage.
Oh, you fucker.
Yo, not the bird!
Not the bird!
I mean, it did go like middle, middle, middle.
I take those.
I fucking take those Any a miracle just happened Happy New
Year This is the power of 2026 I could count more than three
For me And a palm too This It truly is A Christmas miracle
Maybe I should switch Uh Tooth time
Happy New Year, everyone.
All right, summit time.
Time to fight the goddamn aliens.
Okay, I have to turn these guys into sheep.
These guys, I'm scared.
Are you fucking kidding?
God, the goddamn exploding things.
All right, up I go.
Oh, my God.
me.
That's on me.
I literally I did.
They were so tiny.
I didn't see them.
That's actually that's my bad.
That's my bad.
They were so tiny.
I mean, I feel like I maxed out my moon already.
Technically, my moon is pretty.
Okay, guys, which one?
Do we try for more Apollo or maxed out my moon even more?
Chat.
Apollo?
Yeah, I gotta say.
I can't really do more with the moon anymore.
Oh my gods, bro.
I hate this guy.
I hate this guy so much because he doesn't turn into sheep.
He doesn't turn into sheep.
Like, what can I do when he catches him?
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
Oh god.
I hate this guy so much.
He's so scary to fight against.
It's fine.
Yeah!
Big damage!
I'm like all damage right now.
It can be such a nuisance, so they say.
What?
Oh, okay.
3%.
After you take damage, I mean...
Alright.
2, right?
I have 5, so it should be.
good i don't know mega cast i don't have time to make a cast
custom to this light yeah to a survival i need to survive oh
i forgot it's just ten dollars it's fine no you don't
understand i'm very bad at this like right now like right
now no you guys don't understand i'm really bad at surviving
all right hey we can fish though Dragoon eats kale.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll never know what path to if you want it I caught a storm
gullet.
I'll never know It's an enigma What the okay, I deserve that
I deserve that
Pomere Hestia.
Wait, what?
When do I?
30%.
I took damage.
Why did not recover?
Hestia?
Oh, I did?
Oh my god, how much damage did I take?
How much damage did I take?
You're like, you did take?
Yep.
Alright, I got this though.
Just in time.
Oh, shit!
That's on me.
I got a little cocky there.
I got a little too excited.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's gonna chase me, isn't he?
I fucking knew it.
I gotta go.
Oh my god, I swear to God, if he chases me again,
yeah easy damage oh thank god i gotta dig a little too
close perish and a blast to damage any surrounding foes hold
to hmm
hmm three for boss yeah okay three for boss all right oh
last time to fight okay we don't i shouldn't jinx myself
potentially last time to fight typhon wait what oh okay no
chat all right good talk good talking i guess dhp I don't
need this right now.
I'm gonna grab HP.
Uh...
I'm grabbing HP.
Alright.
I guess Apollo.
In the name of Hades.
Okay.
What?
That's actually the...
first that is the first legendary we saw in the entire like
Hades too I don't think we saw legendary at all oh guys I
have a feeling I might die in this red guys no this feels
too good to be true this feels too good to be true guys oh
I'm really nervous what oh my god I told you guys this feels
too good to be true there's too big
oh my god okay okay
all right okay that's fine oh god
Oh god!
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh god.
Okay.
Let's see how you like this.
Whoa.
Okay.
Okay,
it's fine.
That's fine.
All right, sheep time.
Okay, why did that not turn into sheep, though?
I said, I said sheep time.
Okay.
Oh, God.
That is everything.
Oh my god
Shit Yes Oh god again Your time is over Take the free win
Yes That fought eradicated Let's go Return to shuttle now Oh
my god they're literally like take the free win queen take
it you deserve it you fucking deserve it typhon's essence
the power to stop oh my god like do you want some extra
bombs oh yeah let's fuck let's go let's get crazy they're
like here's some extra bombs for the ride thank you Zagreus
the celebration bombs
To all my family on the mountain.
Let me pass
Oh my victory palms zero deaths to You forgot about last
night monster hits different coming from Zeus.
Keita thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, bro I won't be surprised if Zeus fuck the fucking
King of monsters We did it guys whoa flower oh my good niece
you were extraordinary truly so far as we can tell no trace
of that monstrosity remains the deed is done typhon is dead
we saved olympus so what do can i live in olympus now my
lord husband has been premature to declare victory before so
i shall not believe a word of this until i hear it from your
lips oh what a very lovely healthy relationship that you two
have the father of all monsters is undone not merely dead
but eradicated using the power of the time no no you're
gonna say it hell for the locker building you hear that
herodia I told you young men and we was certain to prevail
our family always triumphs when we stand together with a
common purpose I remain utterly in shock well now girl if
you have truly quashed that monstrous threat Then do prepare
yourself for all of us to claim we never doubted you at any
point.
My lord husband is already starting If you had not believed
in me Queen Hara then perhaps Typhon would have been here in
my stead So thank you all and now an even greater victory is
within.
Oh my god.
We're getting close.
We're getting so close There's only one last run if I make
it one last run Using a method you employed this very night
If necessary though this power that you witnessed was for
Typhon and And likewise, what we plan for Kronos is fit only
for him.
The Deathless cannot be destroyed unless they threaten the
very fabric of the weavings of the fates.
No time for feasting till the other deed is done, then, yes?
That's fine.
The Titan's forces may grow far more desperate now, a
possibility for which we ought prepare.
We shall lend you all the strength we can for your own final
assault.
Oh, thank God.
They're actually going to help me?
For real?
They're actually... Real?
Beware.
That monster turned the weather such that not even Lord Zeus
or I could stop it properly.
But now he's gone, and we have you to thank.
As we!
As we all around, Grandmother.
Typhon gave in to the combined might of the gods.
I merely concentrated our foul strength.
Now to press this advantage.
Bro, Melody, you gotta stop fucking giving them credit.
What did they do?
Who slurs one thunderbolt?
That's not might of all gods.
Perhaps not even Kronos can withstand what you unleashed.
It's all you, girl.
Make certain we shall meet again.
We will.
I know.
We did it.
You got him.
Yeah, it's me.
Not that my faith in you wavered since your initial victory.
It's just...
I still can't entirely believe it.
So now for Kronos, then.
They're giving you...
I have to pay for it.
What the...
Yeah, yeah.
Giving me boo.
They charged me for boo.
I'm certain you could use it.
With Prometheus and such still causing problems, we won't be
getting all too comfortable just yet.
Especially not while our main foes out there still.
Go get him sunshine.
Alright, here we go.
Should help you get home.
Wait, if I kill Typhon, who the fuck replaces him?
If I do another surface run.
I'll be counting on your blessings, everyone.
actually kill him later return to shadow now don't worry
this relation is bad Zeus has like 20 other wise thank you
was super check well did you thank you keep holding on
everyone I don't understand if I killed him how am I he's
gone is he actually gone now that one major threat remains
one way to find out smile I got brood real quick guys are
you growing more motivated to find your family or merely
growing more oh jesus she is brooding see you all again
later again huh dora i have a favor if you're not too busy
my task means i no longer can oversee the renewal project
around here would you attend typhon but with a mustache
it's typhoon there that's not typhoon it's typhoon there
it's tyrone
i know i can count on you.
I'll provide the materials.
You'll be the main point of contact.
Okay, fine.
El Typhon.
To your success, it's true, isn't it?
You scoured Typhon from this world.
He's the uncle of all monsters.
Not me have been about his reawakening, but his eradication.
How did you manage this, if I may ask?
complicated incantation from headmistress alongside the
essence of Guygaros.
My father's spear he took up after Kronos' vest was
overthrown.
It all worked out.
Your father's spear in what I saw a spear could be seen
piercing through the storm.
That's me!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good morning from Germany.
Good luck, donkey.
Thank you!
We are going to complete our first game of 2026.
Do they anticipate I shall slay Kronos next?
I'm gonna pick up trash, trash, trash, trash.
I stockpile so much trash.
Aris, you said before that I don't even know what I'm
missing.
What did you mean by that?
Didn't mean your family, that's for sure.
Come on, look at yourself.
You've never lived a day in your life.
That heart beating in your chest, you think it's only there
to pump your blood.
Just another muscle.
The heart is a muscle.
Yeah.
Stupid.
When Olympus is in peril in the underworld and out of
disarray.
Maybe.
But you just want everything nice and orderly and
predictable and boring.
I mean, that's fine.
I mean, I'm okay.
Oh my god, is this...
Wait, decorate.
What shall it be, witch?
Oh!
I couldn't decorate this place.
I'm not decorating this for you guys.
I am not.
Return from online.
Oh my god, finally.
We can make it.
We can proceed.
Time overstepped his bounds, which cannot stand.
He shall be stopped as the three fates had planned.
Death to Kronos.
We're finally actually doing death to Kronos.
Oh, can I decorate my room?
Oh, I can.
Kronos.
What do I do with Kronos?
Boy, I want better bedding, though.
Let's make it happen.
Sure.
Yay!
I get a real bed now.
Yeah!
And then...
I don't know.
I'm getting something fine.
That's all I want.
I just want an actual bed.
Oh, okay.
I can finally recycle.
I'm a musky truck son.
Carefully said.
Oh my god, I can finally fucking recycle now.
Surge of fresh air.
Oh wait, actually I can make...
Oh, did I already make it?
Oh, I already did.
Oh wait, what?
Wait, what does this mean?
What does that mean?
What move is that?
Oh my god, I can fucking finally...
Get rid of that shit.
Oh.
Make Kronos weak to slow.
Oh, okay.
I have enough for that.
Guys, I don't have enough for that.
What the fuck?
I'm broke?
I mean, I could sell this.
Do I have just enough?
Oh, I just have enough.
Oh, thank God.
Just in case.
Oh, I can decorate this as well.
Uh, we'll grab this.
You have it now.
Time cannot be withstood, not even by itself.
Yeah!
Oh, thank god, I just, just able to afford it.
Wait, what are your stuff do I have in here?
Spreading of ashes.
I mean, it doesn't really matter.
Full grown.
Yeah, I have olives.
And soon.
I can't even do with olives.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, all right.
The foul deed is done.
Potentially last run.
Gratitude for yielding his power in his absence.
Ready for the final phase.
Oh my god.
It's time.
My brother has something I didn't know how to answer.
If Kronos is destroyed before all this, what exactly happens
to us?
What do I add that, too?
I was like, don't we cease to exist?
The truth of it together.
I am certain only that this is not goodbye.
The conclusion of your task is...
Does that mean I'll have my real hand back?
I have my real eyes?
I'll see you again soon.
hey they're saying you got rid of typhon for good don't
believe a word of it what really happened up there got rid
of typhon for good is a concise way to put it involved a
rather yeah guys they keep telling me i got rid of him for
good guys details best left unspoken i guess you see el
typhone uncle of all monsters he's immortal he can't just
yeah oh wait what if he is why not just do the
long enough but they told me he's gone we've something else
in store for Kronos as for everybody else they haven't
crossed me quite as much just yet what they said he's all
gone my instinct is to celebrate the death of Typhon but I
never forgot the first man I slew or the light left his eyes
Typhon sought destruction and he got it I won't rejoice in
the outcome but won't lament it either especially when
there's more left to be done you have the right approach
you'll have time to recount every choice and consequence
when all of this is over but for now best to press on and
finish what you started all right i intend to it's finally
time death to cronos death to cronos let's go i can store
different arrangements of arcana now it's finally death to
crone okay let's see all
right what should we upgrade chat what would be the best
upgrade i have three left we're gonna use one will i upgrade
one of them what do you think is the best for the last one
all the speed which one's that wayward sun which one's this
one
all right so that's it That's it.
I grab the Zeus.
I can decorate this too.
You got it.
That's me.
Commander, what is the consensus here about Prometheus?
If some mortals venerated him, perhaps you and your
disciples feel conflicted that he now opposes us.
The Titan who brought fire, reason, good eats and the arts.
and stuff the mortal kind then face the vengeance of the
gods for all of that can't stand the guy let him have it
what that seems like good things that seems like pretty good
things even though he did so much yeah i was gonna say yeah
i was like wait what's the what's the bad side let's see has
he been nice to you or has he tried to kill you so what have
we butted Yeah, clearly he's a very bad guy.
How dare he give me good food?
Fuck that shit.
I'll argue what the gods want me to eat.
For the gods.
Alright.
Should we do money or Zeus chat?
I feel I get less money in the underworld.
That's why I don't know.
What do you guys say?
Because in the past we went with the money, the gold purse.
But Zeus has been working.
He has been.
All right, we'll go with Zeus.
If he ain't broke, don't fix it.
You're right.
For my family.
Ah, your journey begins anew again, young lady.
Though let's see how it goes for you when you have my
incomparable blessing from the start.
All right, here we go.
I haven't done this one in a fucking long time.
Oh my gosh, just get that one again.
I'll ratify it.
do special.
Alright, update.
May I get an alter it?
No thanks.
Okay.
That's okay.
Sure.
Just share, I guess.
Yeah, yeah.
Hammer.
Oh.
one last sheet for the ride if we get the sheet if we're
lucky enough oh my god this area feels so much nicer it's in
the surface world
yeah one enchanted for the night guys do you guys like that
i'm freewheeling it i'll do health i need regen so badly
though Jesus Christ, I really need...
I really need a 3-gen.
But I'm freewheeling it!
Arachne was here.
What the fuck?
She's laughing at me.
Oh, why are you laughing at me?
Oh, there it is.
to transform it it's fine it's fine it's you as me so then
the gods above are helping you aren't they so why do i even
ask you probably want to transform oh i see these woods
light up with all their multicolored messages oh i should
went for the boss fight i feel like i'd rather get the pump
because i always wasted it i should have told you it's just
i didn't know what to say
so the fate's got me again I may be a better weaver than all
the gods combined but those three beat me every time so
don't worry I won't turn my abdomen on you even if the gods
will benefit oh
oh my new channel all right let's hope I can keep it I don't
have a lot of money yeah i remember this road i i don't get
a lot of money what the fuck oh my god i don't remember this
guy who is this guy who who is it who the fuck is this guy
oh my god my fucking thing i already lost all
right that's fine i'm just gonna shoot it from here you
should have stayed Never seen you before.
Alright.
Alright, one or two, chat.
I think it was the first time I ever fought that three?
You think that'll be worth it?
Is that worth it?
I mean, purple is a pre...
Okay, I'll try it.
I can finish too.
Can't hide from me.
The shadow of a skulking killer now is gone.
Presumably after it drifted from the crumbling of Vera
streets in search here of a target.
That cutthroat came to me.
Yeah, I've never fought- I feel like I've never fought that
guy before.
Oh hey, oh my god are you gonna- These wretches were
nothing.
Back when we used to spar.
Almost never got a clean hit in on you.
You'd always slip out of the way.
What choice did I have?
One clean hit from you was more than I could take back then.
Yeah, I'm stronger now.
I got better.
You're tougher, yeah.
Though by how much?
Oh, you're literally fighting in level one.
That ain't a flex, girl.
Huh?
Sure.
Bro, your best hit is 13.
Damage she really wants to hit me.
She That's so sad.
I mean, I'll take it.
My pleasure Oh my guys my armor.
Okay, that's fine.
It's not it didn't even hit me hit me.
It was my armor That's still oh, okay.
It's okay.
I didn't want the money anyway She didn't even actually hit
me.
That's the saddest part I should I should just go and chat
Because, like, it's super strong right now, I forgot.
Damn.
I'll go for a palm.
Her muscles are performative, yeah.
I agree.
It's actually sad.
Like, it's just sad now.
I think that's all of it.
Be again at peace.
One or two, chat.
It's palm tab.
What?
The underworld's power.
I feel like I've, like, given everyone nectar already.
But I don't have...
I have no use for ash.
That's the only thing.
I have no use for ash right now.
There you go.
Nice.
Nectar.
Why is this area?
This area is new.
I've never seen this room before.
To be unseen is to become as missed.
Oh my god, I ran out.
Okay, this is bad.
I really need mana regen.
I just realized.
Oh, this is so bad for me.
Actually.
Okay, let's hope everything will be fine.
Alright, nice.
Last guy.
Stay where you are.
Stay here!
Uh, I guess we're in Blitz.
Uh, is this the last room or not?
Chat.
I can't tell.
Is this the last room?
It's been a while.
We're here.
Because I can just go to the store now.
No?
Should I just go to Apollos, uh, Hermes then?
It is?
You don't have a lot of money, so I get...
Yeah, I only have 173.
Hmm.
I'll go for Hermes.
I really need, like...
Yeah, it is the last one.
Okay.
I think he's gone for good.
He can't believe it still.
But there has been no sign of that monstrosity up here since
you last took him on.
But why am I surprised?
I figured if anyone could pull something like that off, it
would be you.
Oh.
That's good.
Alright, Hekatee time.
You know, Hekatee should just let me through.
I just...
What?
It seems the pathways into Erebus are not as well protected
as they used to be.
the individual who pitted you against me is this not no
how's he gonna know about that headmistress headmistress
fight him fight fight back can just walk past oh oh oh no oh
no his headmistress of yours has considerable knowledge to
have thus concealed you but she is weary it's up to that
time caught up with her That was a joke, Hekatee.
No, I'll fight you again, Hekatee.
It's okay.
I was just joking.
I have children taught me to pieces once before.
Look where I got them.
Whoever this is, perhaps she shall be more cooperative than
you.
Although I'm not particularly optimistic, nor should you be.
Good evening.
Come back.
Oh, wait.
Hey, free room.
Never mind.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Wait, actually.
No, that's fine.
Take her away.
Yay.
Free room.
I thought she was going to fight fucking.
I thought I had to fight him.
I mean, this is actually very.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was like going to say, like, I should be able to pass this
room for free.
Hold on.
I did.
Yippee.
Thanks, Grownos.
I guess I'll get the concave stone.
Yeah.
Win-win!
I like my frog did a little bounce there.
Alright.
The hater is back.
I still need regen.
Holy fuck this is so bad.
We have yet to find regen right now.
What?
Oh, no, I broke the thing.
That's not good.
That's actually not good.
I got...
I lacked...
I lacked information.
I lacked crucial information.
Okay, it's fine.
I actually needed money.
I like crucial information.
Oh, hey, duo!
Okay, which one was harder again?
Oh, which one was easier, guys?
Who do I pick?
Actually, no, let me face this.
Who do I pick first?
Anyway, we have Chaos, too.
Pick Zeus?
I know that what Poseidon does.
Okay.
Uh...
One or three, chat.
Because they both seem good.
One?
Oh, it's split.
Okay, I'll do three.
God, okay, I mean, sure.
He's like, I mean, to be fair, it is so, but like, you know,
I still gotta do something, you know.
You're like, you know what I mean?
It is true, so, like, fair.
That's fair.
That's funny.
It is like broken, you know?
I get it, but still.
What is this?
Oh, this is the restore?
I had to like look at that.
I don't like that mana restore.
your texts
one one
or two or
three two they're all men all right I'm gonna do chaos oh
but there's narcissists oh come on bro my oh she's in there
oh oh Oh my god.
It was the hardest choice of my life.
If this is your father.
No, I should have seen my own sheet.
I'll never see him again.
Which do you think is fun?
The father of all monsters is destroyed.
I should have went and saw the other sheet.
I should have saw him.
Oh my god, I can't believe I picked this bitch over Maoshi.
But if you fail, you should see him again.
I would learn from Doki to see my other team.
I'm so sad though.
I'm so sad.
I'll do one.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's a boss fight.
Oh my god, okay.
I should have seen my Ushi.
I should...
I should have went for him.
It truly was.
Oh my god, wait, he's dead.
Okay, that's fine.
Wait, that was fast as fuck.
What the fuck?
My damage was insane even had a heart as there was not a
trace of love in him at all only the worst intentions and
desires so much for those oh i feel like i should get
spiritual affection all right two or three chat two or three
all right that which slithers seeps and crawls all it
thrives within the foul air and crushing climate near the
bottom grab the shop i should be able to afford something
right i should have money for something now right i do thank
god do you think arachne is going to be all right in all of
this my lord the surface was no longer welcoming or safe for
her and now i feel that arabus is not much better off
You're right.
She's twice as resourceful as Spidey.
She's a spider.
She'll be okay.
I believe it, hey?
Oh, plus 20?
Oh!
Volcanic strike, guys.
Or two.
Fuck, they're all good.
Or three.
Army.
Army or or 400?
Three?
Oh, okay.
I'll do it.
Also grab this since it's here.
I mean, 25 is pretty.
One or three, chat.
One or three.
Oh my god, it's perfectly divided.
It's half, half.
Oh my god, you guys...
One.
It'll be crazy.
I'm actually pressed two there.
It was that close to actually pressing two.
It was actually perfectly half.
Oh my god.
I'm a little scared because they do 35% more damage.
And I'm worried about that.
I do not think I can survive that.
Okay.
I feel like I have like a lack of damage right now.
Oh my god, there you are.
I was like wondering where you guys are.
Where are the others?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
I was like, where's the last guy?
Ha!
Gamba.
That's Gamba time.
I'm so poor.
And this is...
Should this be my last encounter?
Oh, shit.
Just gonna go destroy this real quick.
Jesus Christ.
We're fine.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
out of here.
No, I have two more.
Fucking hell, I have two more?
Alright.
Oh.
I don't think I have a lot.
No, I don't have money.
Health?
Or Hermes?
No money?
Hermes?
Alright, Hermes.
God, I've been like, so broke.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna be broke forever.
Come on.
Look at it.
Oh my god, I'm being so fucking poor.
Is it worth being broke forever?
Like...
Did she broke forever?
Oh my god, two legendaries and one fucking...
In one day?
I'll never have money again.
Oh my god, this is so hard.
Yeah, I've only can do one and...
Wait, if I get three, maybe I'll get one later.
No, I actually want to win this run, guys.
I'm worried.
Guys, I do want to win this run, guys.
I'm sorry.
It is very tempting.
It is.
Oh my god.
I know.
Look at that.
He gave me, look at that.
A gambit.
It was worth the gambit.
I got the, I got the, I got the, three could save your life.
Kaboom, coward.
If, if I was a coward, why did Poseidon reward me?
Temptation resistant.
Guys, no, no, no, you could have had 300 HP.
Guys, I'd be broke forever, guys.
I had to fight them!
Don't worry, girls.
One day, they'll put us up on the biggest stage for all the
world to see.
Hello, your auntie is back.
You thought you saw the last of me when I didn't show up for
two days?
Oh, wait, even more than two days.
For like several weeks.
Oh, it may be a little song, do you know, lady?
But it's going to be huge someday.
You'll see.
We'll show her, won't we, girls?
I am.
I'm a little worried about myself.
I am just a little worried, guys.
Oh my god.
A lot of damage.
Oh,
I can't actually remember that.
Who is it?
Oh, it's her.
Ginny!
Go, Ginny, go!
Oh my god, okay, it's fine.
All right, nice.
There you go.
Oh my god, there's a double?
All right, last one.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's okay, it's just the armor.
Alright, last one.
It's fine.
It's fine, right?
Yeah, it's fine!
Just don't get hit.
It's fine.
Oh, see, they're cheering.
They didn't even want to hear you sing, girl.
They cheered for me.
They're like, oh my god, finally someone showed her up.
Oh.
Okay, uh, knuckle bones.
Alright.
Straight down.
Yanti won again.
They cheered for it, too.
So in the end, I didn't do a bad thing.
Yeah, they're like, fucking finally.
Someone finally got them off the stage.
Where the fuck- Oh, it's over here.
I feel like the entrance changes every time.
Does it?
Or I'ma just schizo about it.
Yeah.
I don't know if my damage is okay.
Oh my god, there's the goddamn shades.
Oh, I did not see these guys.
Oh, these guys.
Oh, nice.
My chaos disappeared.
What even was it?
What was my chaos?
Oh, HP.
Oh, nice.
Oh, there's shields here.
I'm gonna grab the shields just in case.
All right, nice.
Oh, it was cast damage?
Oh, okay.
That's always good.
Okay, nice.
All right, hammer time.
channel plus 30 to deal 300 i'll cry at drag get the i've
not have the moon power yet so i'm a little worried just a
little bit i'm i'm just a little i'll do one
yeah i'm i'm a little worried about the lack of moons
oh what the Should I take Hef?
Or there's three, though.
I mean, I guess.
That's one Hef, and this is three.
This gives me three, though.
Also, under, thank you for the red.
Thank you.
I've had a great stream.
Oh.
I'm going to go for three.
Three is better than one.
I'm risking it.
Oh my god, there's a lot of shit actually here.
I am a little worried about my damage though.
It's not that much and that concerns me.
That makes me just a little nervous.
I can't see shit.
So I hope I'm hitting something.
Oh my god, it's these guys.
Oh my god, not this guy.
Okay, we'll grab the bones.
Is my damage really bad?
It feels bad, but I can't tell.
Okay, I'll grab the HP and then I'll grab.
I just need attack palm.
Boom.
Okay.
I mean, that makes sense.
Stop punching.
I demand you to stop.
Hello.
Sir, stop.
Alright.
Oh, yeah!
Oh my god.
Wait, the scamba is paying off so hard.
Bro, it was a 25%, but the 25% is hitting like 100% times.
It's actually crazy.
Let's see.
One, two, or three.
Okay, quick maps.
One?
All right, one time.
There we can go.
Moon?
Moon power?
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
Maybe I can buy the moon.
Oh.
Wait, there's another thing I can...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I can't buy the moon.
Okay, I mean, okay, that works.
That works.
Oh.
One?
Alright.
I don't need that, actually.
I guess we have to go here.
We need more palms.
Or we need more booms.
I am not a fan of my build right now, chat.
I feel very, very weak.
I do not feel confidence.
Where is he?
There he is.
I was gonna say, where the fuck is he?
Oh no, oh no, I'm sad.
Okay, that's bad.
God damn the fucking Medusas.
Medusas are the most annoying!
Oh my god, take this.
God, it takes forever!
Oh, yeah.
I don't feel very confident with this one.
I'll grab more army.
It's something.
Oh, hey!
At least I get my gamma.
I mean, I'm fine.
I'll take the gamma.
I'll go grab.
Get on the stairs real quick.
Alright.
Hey, more gamma.
Oh, God.
Not her.
Oh, no.
I'm so bad with these.
Oh, my God.
He just keeps doing it and I let her just let it happen
I don't know what it is about it I have three oh wait no I
don't use uh
Two or three Two All right, we'll go to
Okay, I'll grab the money real quick.
And then, and it was Zeus.
Still no moon.
And it's making me very nervous right now.
Making me very nervous.
Oh my god, I can't believe I missed.
because i
was thinking about the moon that's how i missed it
hit double strike
the whole this one is always so good for me though i mean
okay shop that's just it is it just a shop
Yeah, I wanted to use it for Cerberus.
Oh my god, there's still...
Are you serious?
Where?
I...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, I'm gonna do security system.
This is gonna clutch it.
I think...
Yeah, the moon has definitely been banished.
The moon no longer haunts me.
No.
The moon no longer haunts me, guys.
Oh.
I'm a little worried because I don't feel great about my
build.
That's the only issue.
Holy shit, never mind.
That's a lot of damage.
Never fucking mind.
Bro, if only I could turn all these guys in.
the sheep, though.
If only I could turn all these guys into sheep.
Oh my god.
Fucking Corey C.
That just moves away.
Grab this.
Oh.
Oh, that hits me.
Okay, that's fine.
It's okay.
Is that safe?
Oh, I am.
Oh!
It's a hit.
One last...
One last 30 damage on me.
That's a kit.
Unmired for the moment.
Fearsome Cerberus gives the princess an appreciative look.
Alright, he's happy again.
Bye.
Mining.
One last mining.
All right, down I go.
Down, I'll go.
He did hit me, but like 30 damage, though, which I did not
like that.
All right, Death Defiance.
Sure, the next boon is rare.
To the calculating Titan of Time rested control of the
underworld.
He sealed shut the major artery from Tartarus.
yet the princess of the dead knows of a hidden passageway
within oh yep here it is here's the hidden door knock knock
oh no this build is so strange I think this is the weirdest
build I've ever done you got this Melanie wait I'm not I'm
wearing shoes?
I just noticed that.
Oh my god, Mellowy.
That is not safe.
Mellowy, you were in the forest!
I just noticed that I'm shoeless.
Where is he?
Your feet are on fire.
All right, there's a duo.
At least there's a duo, Pum.
All right.
Is Aphrodite hard or not?
Family dispute.
You're keeping those posies out.
Oh!
I have eight.
Wait, I have to get this.
Okay, I have to get this.
have to get two.
Because I feel like two would be really good during the last
fight.
Because I don't have to run into them.
Yeah, I don't have to run into them.
Oh, you my blessings.
You can just save them for later.
Like some sort of snap.
Oh, she's angry.
You can have it.
I don't know what she does.
And I...
Oh, Oh, it's a heart that follows me.
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
It takes a while for it to follow me.
Oh my god, it's getting closer though.
It's...
It follows me for a very long time, but it's okay.
It still takes a while.
Okay, it's okay.
I don't know where it is though right now.
There he is, God.
It's like the snail that follows you.
It follows.
It's like the...
The horror film guy, it follows.
Huh?
One or three?
I am not getting two.
Because we're going to lose a lot of health.
Or one?
Three safe there?
Oh, I will do safe.
Oh my god, that's a lot of HP.
I know I say it's a lot, but I'm confident.
that I will lose that HP very fast.
All right, nice.
Triple palms.
Oh my god, triple palms!
That's a lot of palms!
Oh god.
That actually was very scary.
I got very worried here.
What the fuck it hit me?
There you go.
One, two, or three, guys.
Pum-pums.
Pum-pum-pum.
All right.
One.
Two.
Oh.
Okay, one.
I see more.
Oh, yeah!
Oh.
We're not doing Gamma, guys.
We're not doing Gamma again.
He's already spoiling me with Gamma.
What?
Yay!
More Gamma!
Gamma Infinite.
I thought it was just great.
It says 25% but I've been getting unlimited Gamma.
It's actually crazy how much Gamma I've been getting.
oh my god like i i can't see anything right now it's oh
there's so much stuff on my screen there's act there's way
too much shit on my screen right now i'm i'm so confused
all right nice oh wait i could get more stuff i could get
more
oh fuck okay
my i
love locked him nice hello oh my god I can have more HP away
your attacks and specials deal more damage to armor guys I
can have so much HP guys wait can I oh my I'm at almost at
400 I'm oh my god and I have more money oh
my god i could be greedy forever it's truly i could be
greedy forever never punish i
can't see i can't see i i actually can't see right now
there's so much shit on my screen.
Okay, now I should have...
There's no more stuff, right?
Yeah, there's no more.
Okay, I'll just kill him.
Like, fuck this guy.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
It's fine.
Yeah!
Something here, right?
Oh, yeah, I can't be greedy no more.
I took everything.
I'm just surprised we haven't talked to Hades yet, you know?
You would think that Hades would show up right now.
Oh, my.
It's just all guns.
It's literally just all guns.
I can't see anything.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
Hades never showed up.
I never saw my dad.
Where's where's poppy?
Don't you want to Don't you want to It's the final showdown
You want to say hi to your kid?
My dad
Jesus Christ Oh my god Alright it's fine It's not dope but
like it's fine She Jesus
Oh my god, there's too much stuff
Okay, oh my god, please
There you go there's so much shit on my screen What No Stop
the dead They actually never came back That's so fucked
that's actually so fucked 444 3 I get double Zeus, but dad
never came home All right You guys decide I go pee you guys
figure this out
All right, I'm back solid right Nexy many thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
What have we decided?
That's the hot man What have we decided guys
Three All right, three.
All right, and then we'll grab one more here.
Oh, my God, they keep giving me...
I have so much Zeus shit right now.
I think majority of this is just Zeus.
Only Uncle.
I only see Uncle.
Two.
Okay.
And now grab extra shield.
And then, I mean, fucking...
I don't have any...
That way.
Oh, yay!
Credit card!
Here we go.
I can't believe we didn't fucking see the Hades at all.
Where is she?
Where is that Katia?
She is now my guest.
It should really be fine, right?
I call that old witch whom you seem to care about so much.
Your head is just...
Out of 1,900.
You can now exactly who she is if you yet value her
well-being in the least.
She was my mother's handmaiden.
Nothing more.
Yeah.
She's not special.
Here I go.
She took me away.
When I came of age, I vowed to stop you, despite her efforts
to dissuade me.
Let her go.
At first, I thought perhaps that you were a child of Zimps
rather than Hades.
But you are a terrible liar, granddaughter.
You shall suffer for your actions, or the handmaidens shall
do so in your stead.
That was actually crazy.
I didn't get a single moon power.
That's insane.
Oh my god, it was so sensitive that it like fucked me up.
I did not mean to do that
That was actually I did not mean to fuck that up
Are you serious?
That was an accident I did not see I did not see that move
at all So like, it like confused me
Alright, I'll get rid of this, though
There you go I'm gonna get rid of this just in case Okay
Really?
That hurts me?
Oh my god That also hurts me.
Fuck off.
There you go.
Are you fucking- Okay.
That's okay.
Okay, that's fine.
I can't see, but that's okay.
I don't need a C.
Yeah!
We're tanky.
Okay, where is it?
Okay.
Alright, it's a fight.
Oh my god, I can't see shit.
I can't see shit in this world.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we can't let you heal.
No, no, no, no, no.
This is not fair.
Okay.
okay are
you fucking kidding me
oh okay there's one more phase oh there's one more phase
what have you been give you water glimpse come finish what
you're following Ask yourself, where do you think you are?
Where am I?
Don't buy a gun!
I'm so confused!
I don't know!
But by all means, please go ahead and try.
I'll do it, you idiot!
Oh.
Oh
Oh my gosh, I don't I'm so confused Wait, I actually might
lose this I'm so confused
Oh Oh Oh where is where are you oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god what's going on oh
my god i don't like this i miss you don't understand i am
perpetually i'm so confused
Okay, I need this.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay, 400 HP was a little too much.
Oh!
What reason would they have to care?
Look what you've done.
You're trying to take everything from us.
Our future.
we are family we do not take we share destroy me then if you
possess strength and see what future you shall bring about
this is for that future and our family
we did it we stopped time wait for now we did it Yeah,
I got it We fucking did it Oh, I actually was ready for a
phase four.
I was the I was ready for a phase four guys I was expecting
one Oh Where now oh I had infinite revives.
Oh, thank God No, that that fight was crazy.
I was so fucking confused I thought to hold you a little
extra time for what comes next oh that's cool out of
infinite i i that's cool i was like 400 that 400 hp was a
lot actually took me to the end subconscious i descend oh my
god okay all right zyrus better fucking do his part of the
deal night and darkness guide me to my blood beyond the
grasp of time
Hello.
Hello, brother.
Brother?
I'm here.
You've returned.
You've no idea how much difficulty I had falling asleep so I
could see you here again.
So what's the word?
Have you prepared the spear?
Take hold of Gagaros and we'll find out.
You'll have to go immediately to where Kronos resides.
Speak to him, but do not mention me at all as I've not yet
been born.
I'll be counting on you to succeed.
Yeah, I heard the old ending was really shit, so I wonder...
Is this the new ending where they fixed the shitty ending,
apparently?
Or else it's death to Kronos, like you said.
Do you truly think there's any possibility he comes around
that I won't have to kill him?
Knowing there are infinite possibilities, then I suppose so,
yes.
But I'm so angry with him still.
Oh.
I'm frightened about what may come to pass.
He's taken so much from me.
of us and yet he wants his family back too one way or
another he'll get what's coming we all will okay but we're
getting your family back not just his this is a lot to think
the spear of fathers has the power to destroy a deathless
Titan it shall in just a moment so hold it close may earth
and night in darkness hear me now bring true by my vow to
solution of time oh my god it's a it's incantation i used i
mean it's grown hot to the touch but feels much lighter than
before as well i suppose i should be careful not to prod
somebody with it besides chronos go zagrius i've done
everything i can here and we'll see each other again some
other time than this perhaps but still for now farewell
Goodbye, my enemy.
I hope this works.
Tartarus?
Huh?
What?
It's not over?
What is all that infernal racket?
Science fools has to be caught.
Oh, I'm coming over!
Hello, I'm here.
Hello, grandpappy.
Mad.
You must be grandfather.
I don't believe we've had the pleasure.
I'm called Zagreus.
I got to tip about your quite suspicious cabin and decided
to go take a look.
What are you doing here if I may ask?
Incorporated.
What else would I possibly be doing in a place such as this?
So I suppose Hendy is just a thing for this new grandchild
of mine.
And I thought that I would see the age when he became a
father for himself.
Oh, he's a wonderful father, if you must know.
My sole disappointment is that I'm an only child.
But he and my dear mother, Persephone, the underworld queen,
truly love each other.
So down the line.
Yeah, it's just me.
No other child.
Nope, just me.
That's...
Bro, you're killing it, bro.
Not suspicious.
I am a tetanus.
Yeah, he's like, what does fuck do I care that you're an
only child, bro?
Right, even Kronos is like, um, okay.
No, this.
Grandfather, I'm telling you all this.
Yeah, you had one job.
If you would bring pain and suffering upon my house.
So smooth.
Thumbs up.
Do you know what my intent?
It is victim to your pain and suffering.
Here I have wrought it since an yarm prior to when you were
about the twinkle in your father's eyes.
There, twinkle in your father's eyes, like, since you were
in his balls.
That's a nice way to say it.
He'd grown isolated from Olympus and Persephone and me.
Didn't do him any good.
What about you?
We've only met.
Are you prepared to sweep me into your old grudge?
That's a nice way to say it, though.
Your father and his brothers surely have already poisoned
you with your entire generation against me.
What I'd be speaking to you if that were the case?
Here's the arrangement.
Either come along quietly to a little surprise family
reunion, or take this spear repeatedly.
And you won't soon recuperate, I swear.
Which is it going to be?
You, who threatened me with annihilation, have not
experienced a wealth without time.
would have to dearly miss my influence nor shall i be shamed
and rid of you before my team what do you have me do when
they look upon me oh i don't know perhaps just act like
you're my grandfather sneaking underneath the house in some
sort of profane chamber i ought to have known about your
time why don't you extrapolate a bit extrapolate what
actually feel the life
Oh He's like I'm not here to be a grandpa No, because you'll
be under my protection and also no it won't just be a
joy-filled life Especially if you keep on but it'll probably
be better than whatever this is.
It's like fuck that shit I don't have all day your night
Selen a future with such grandchildren as you or the eternal
void
That's it.
I'm stabbing you.
It's like a way too long.
It's like Jacob.
Whatever.
Fuck this.
I'm done talking.
Three, two, one.
What?
Ready or not.
Hence, I go.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, wait, what?
I'm a grandpa.
What the fuck?
I tried to blow a seat now.
Wait, what?
I'm going to leave my daughter unattended.
Oh my god, I'm doing grandfather's things now.
I've grandpa simulated it.
Well, this is a rare treat.
The both of you together in this lounge.
What brings you here, grandfather?
I yet to see you.
I beat him up and now he's willing to be a grandpa.
I have turned over this residence in its entirety and found
nary a sign.
She is already as elusive as you always were, Hades.
Now though your old senses have dulled, she went running
over there by the head chef, where she yet lingers in
silence.
Go before her patience wears things.
Wasn't the issue was that I'll eat people?
What if I get hungry?
Was no, we've no idea where my good son's little sister is.
She could be anywhere.
Oh, Zagorus is his favorite grandchild.
Yeah, he wanted to talk to him.
And he over here.
Oh, there you...
Oh, she's over there.
Well, alright, let's pretend we didn't see her, because I
wasn't...
Yeah, oh, I can go here.
Yeah, it wasn't the whole issue was that...
He likes to eat people, especially kids.
Like, what do we do about that?
Like, he's still gonna be hungry, right?
there you are at last you might have kept me searching for a
while yet that you found such a secure hiding point amid
those shadows it sure took you long enough i was getting to
think oh there she is that's me that is precisely what your
father said no one in hell wears shoes well how are we to
suffer through another round no this game is too easy tell
me another one of your tales about the golden age perhaps
when you are older lest your father be displeased if you
defy him you merely get a mild reprimand if i defy him i get
cut to little bite-sized bits oh okay i mean that's a child
but okay oh she's like ew that's gross grandpa that's not
gonna happen Spoken with the generosity of youth.
You are the only one around here.
Aww, I'm her favorite.
But don't see others like you, Grandfather.
Aww.
Oh, they can never get enough of me, my girl.
Except we still have had our differences.
But let me not concern you with the past.
The only time that matters is right now.
And right now...
You are it!
Oh my god, I did it!
I won the game!
Is this the future?
Or is it the past?
Not merely mine, but yours, granddaughter.
Everybody in this house.
What?
Wasn't this create a paradox?
Ah, that's cute!
Oh my god, I'm getting better.
I get to keep my arm!
Oh he's still sleeping.
Yeah, this has to be another timeline.
Oh, I'm learning history.
I'm grandfappy.
Oh, I'm talking to Zagreus' many girlfriends now.
I finally won!
Oh my god, he lost to a child!
That's embarrassing, bro.
Oh!
I'm learning from my step, my other mom.
Huh?
My life, the way it could have been.
Oh.
Oh gods, Zagreus, did it work?
No, I still lost my other arm.
It's been one up there.
What?
I mean, I still have my other arm.
I don't know if it worked.
Prepare to suffer for all that you've done, Wretch.
Or shall I stay my hand merely because you made the mistake
of loosening your hold on me?
All of these newfound thoughts.
Oh.
Look at my mind.
all of this you're doing which i have no memory of you and
yet who are you chronos head mistress wait i can i think i
can explain malinois where are we one instant i discovered
that our enemy invaded arabus the next i know he's grobbling
about my feet how is this possible what have you done
Headmistress, you don't remember because you weren't there
with me.
But as for you, Kronos, who am I now to you?
You are my granddaughter, Melinui, whom I know both from
this life and an altogether different one.
I created a parallel...
I created a parallel universe, a timeline.
is this so i created a parallel timeline all that you see is
what you wrote as for this other life how much of it do you
recall yeah your youth here in this house with me are you
delighted in a hiding game when you were but a girl have you
been saturated fight but out of love not in the way we
fought this very night i did not realize there could have
been this other past we shared this better past oh we merged
the timeline we synced it up now he has feelings nonsense
none of it occurred nothing has changed you should be gone
Titan not flooded with false memories all these memories
that spring to his mind I remember them as well a life I
could have lived had the Titan never struck but I struck
ever hated and shunned finish what you set your mind to
grand altar I have no desire to exist in such a world with
all of you like this oh no he's like I was happy oh silence
millenoy come to your senses whatever you did is finished
and shan't be using his old tricks again end him wait please
let me prove this to you chronos grandfather listen to me
steady yourself use what power you yet have and release our
family from your hold it's like i could actually have love
oh my god he actually has feelings now he's real He's a real
boy.
What the fuck?
Wait, is he also?
My family.
Where are we?
Is this my house?
Father, what is the meaning of all this?
Yes, he feels guilt now.
He's no longer a sociopath.
Yippee!
Oh, Hades.
Perhaps the princess can explain.
As for the queen and prince and all the rest.
He's scared now.
We fixed him.
I told you we can fix him.
What?
What is Warren?
What happens if I warn him?
Does anything bad happens if I do warn?
I can't speak to anybody.
Talk to him first.
Wait, do I release them first or talk to him?
Which was a...
He gets one more.
What do I do first?
Warn him or...
Family.
Just don't do it okay, okay?
Don't do it again, okay, grandpa.
Release.
Warn him.
Free will.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Okay, I'll warn them.
They said better work.
Oh, that's it?
Okay, I'll release.
That's it.
Just better work.
Okay, I thought it'd be something.
I thought we had, like, an actual conversation.
Okay.
You're all grown up.
But then, of course you are.
I...
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Melina, it's really you.
You look just like you.
your nightmare reflection did so long ago before the little
you was even born did we succeed we did it we successfully
weren't they shall recover give them time and give me death
go on and send me to the blasted void already you son or
that witch or you granddaughter one of you for i am weary of
it all you long for a world without me it is yours
grandfather no how could you say that after all we've been
through together i swore you'd be under my protection and oh
gods what happened to this place i took this place as what
zagreus and ruined it you need not advocate for me again you
never knew my real self nearly a possibility and nothing
more and you millenoi the thin guy put you through all this
oh i'm his favorite Oh, wait, that's so sweet.
I was his favorite in the other timeline.
So he's like, oh my God, I took your arm.
No, our families had enough for now.
Who else recalls what happened?
Oh, memories as vivid as any you hold dear, but of a
separate life we might have lived.
Mother, do you remember?
I do.
You were insatiably curious as a child.
and sometimes too much even for me to handle.
So, Zagreus and Kronos, they often helped take care of you.
Ekkity's like, why don't I have any memories?
Because she didn't have to do any of this.
I, too, remember now.
That father was with us after Zagreus discovered him and
took him in.
Yet all the while, I have been a prisoner.
His prisoner here in this time of ours.
Stephanie, Lord Hades, do not believe these falsehoods
coursing through your minds.
Even your son and daughter seem susceptible.
You all have been manipulated by the Titan spell.
Headmistress, that's not true.
Don't you understand?
The dissolution of time, this is how I manifested it.
You always said the task was mine, as were the methods I
employed.
This was the path I chose.
Then you failed.
Oh!
Death to Kronos!
The one task we had the entire time.
Possibly have compelled you to take such a course.
I mean, she is right.
Literally from birth to now.
Remember what we had to do?
Death to Kronos.
And Melanie was like, okay, but...
You had one job, Melanie.
Literally one job.
Her entire fucking mantra was...
death the cronus but but i can have a grand papa yeah but
what is oh i i thought it was just stop cronus stop cronus
stop the cronus your own teachings to think for myself oh
free will it needs to be like free will was a mistake if you
still believe destroying cronus will make our problems go
away then what are you waiting for
I shall never forgive this Titan for what he has done.
To this world, your family, you, or me.
Dear Hackety, my handmaiden, who said anything about
forgiveness?
I've never heard such pain in you.
Therapy to Kronos.
Just before Kronos struck, your task was to protect our
daughter at all costs.
And you did.
You did.
You know, Debt to Kratos is kind of vague.
Does she mean therapy?
In our moment of peril to which of the crossroads?
For that and for all eternity.
Well, that's not gonna...
Bro, she fucking...
Bro, the heck, she lost everything.
And she didn't even get to enjoy the good memories or
anything.
I get it.
She's like, what the fuck?
Like, this guy literally killed all our loved ones and
everything and kidnapped.
He literally kidnapped the fates.
Like, and killed, like, millions of people on the surface
world.
Like, I get it.
I get, like, she's like, what the fuck?
I did know more than was my charge of king and queen.
And I remain as ever at your service.
Well then, Melanoi.
What now?
Hmm.
What do we do?
What now?
There is so much to be done.
Bringing this house to order for one thing.
Father.
To be fair.
Yeah, I'll say to be fair.
Those are people mortals though.
They don't matter.
All right.
Would you grant me that?
Granted.
We're not finished with you, Kronos.
They say time heals all.
Oh, we forgive him.
kronos granted but only this one chance by the grace of the
princess of the underworld so yeah thank you the super chat
thinking thank you technically she killed the old kronos by
fixing him you would permit me such a chance but i cannot
change what already occurred cannot undo the unforgivable
decisions i have made
we're not demanding you move backward we're demanding you
move forward this ending is nice what was the old ending
like to move forward that is all I have ever known then I
shall make time both for this house and everything then be
so kind as to get these chains on me so we can get to work
it's just a Oh, we're rebuilding.
Oh, Melody didn't remember?
To aid in the recovery of however much.
No, that seems like a terrible ending.
They'll be like, they're like, I'll remember all the good
times we had.
Melody's like, what the fuck?
I lost an arm.
What do you mean you remember?
They're still loyal to their cause.
Answered the call.
They and the Titan picked up many pieces of the past.
the house grew more like how it used to be but then a
summons from olympus arrived and the princess knew her stay
had reached its end yeah this definitely sounds a lot better
than uh than the old ending it's like does she train for
this her whole life and then they're like exactly like
sarah's just like um i'm the older brother so we're gonna
spare grandpa after like after she fucking catches to kill
typhoon seven times and then grandpa like another seven
times too like i went through a lot i think we can fix up
the rest of this place on our own thank you for all your
help especially the part where you liberated us from our
temporal prisons and whatnot believe me i had nothing better
to do anyhow we'll have to find a way to cross paths out
there and each keep an eye on chronos as we tie up some new
sends everything you did i can't help but be glad we're all
here but that's easy for me to say not having been locked in
a lifelong conflict i'll manage you helped me realize there
even was a path toward this outcome as i faced oh i might
have consumed him completely good thing that's impressive
brother sister team past and present real and imagined and
now we don't even need dream time which magic to stay in
touch no i suppose not feels like we've been through thick
and thin together doesn't it even without the memories of a
wholly different and generally more pleasant life right now
I'd simply settle for a calmer one come on you're not the
settling sort anyway I know this isn't goodbye and we'll be
seeing each other though still oh I'm going back to the
forest I'm gonna live in the forest I'm going to miss you
too big brother take what but this place looks a lot nicer
but but I could be a princess in a castle oh yeah
triple-headed monster service rests in his favorite spot oh
to Olympus oh that's fine fuck you guys I'm going to Olympus
I'm gonna pet the dog I thought he was sending me to the
woods Fuck you guys.
See you losers.
I'm going to Olympus.
Oh, can I pet him now?
The way my brother demonstrated before.
Bro, the tier is forest, uh, Hades, and then Olympus.
Fuck, of course, I'll pick Olympus.
Yay!
Aww, that's so cute.
Hey.
It's been an honor, sir.
Why is Achilles?
I know.
We'll remember you here, alas.
Shank his ankles.
That's how it still feels as if we've only met.
Shank the heels.
That is Achilles, sir.
I have these glimpses now of cherished moments I might have
spent with you and the other house servants had the past but
gone differently.
Are the others doing well?
They seem to be.
Your relatives recovered the most swiftly, but I think we're
all still feeling some effects.
and catching up on everything we missed and aiding where we
can i'll miss you all this really does feel like a dream at
times i fear i may forget it as one tends to do with dreams
i trust you'll still remember what i always told you about
fear please don't worry and now we may not see you for a
while but i shall await whenever we may meet
Beautiful daughter.
We were just talking about you, how you were as a child,
both in this life and the other.
Growing up is so difficult, and you had to do it twice.
Which makes me beyond fortunate.
Peckety was the best caretaker I can imagine, and I'm so
grateful to have experienced a life with you, Mother, where
there was so much warmth.
And now you've met this other side of me.
And I shall eagerly await getting to know this other side of
you even better.
And Hecate, you're certain it's no burden to me.
What the fuck?
To continue looking after her, just in case.
Wait, what?
Why is I'm...
Why am I...
What?
Why is she...
Still doesn't want...
Does she not love me?
What?
And I shall always care for her.
or not yeah i'm like she like had me down like what do you
mean like do you not want to spend time with your daughter
like you don't even know current me i'm then it's settled
and Malinui for what it's worth I likewise back to boarding
school please reconsider this Malinui you cannot be yeah
yeah Malinui what the fuck you not want to like like bond
with your fucking mom after like never being with her the
unseen is to serve in shadow I know full well had mr.
and do not make this decision lightly but I can't leave the
crossroads oh my god there's so much left to do okay I mean
I wouldn't make that decision but free will I guess working
with Kronos on this new venture of his you've been
instrumental in altering time as we know it so you're
certainly the best fit to keep things that way ensuring time
keeps working in our favor seems like a good way to spend my
own time it should be interesting and the matter is close to
my heart perhaps i was born for this you were born for much
more but we'll do our share yeah the fair child prefers the
wood she's too used to shitting in the forest i guess as for
your brother well he always turns up this is going to be an
adjustment though isn't it even if i'll see you all again
soon
an adjustment is putting it mildly now go make your rounds
and i'll see you off before you depart i love you baby girl
i think that's just a little bit of a plot hole there i feel
like you know after your entire life in the current
iteration of you in this current time like you never got
fucking grow up with your parents or your family and you're
like yeah i'm gonna stay in the that just feels off that i
that that's the only thing i have graves about i love you
too mother that's the only thing i'm like that's weird
that's a weird choice when i was having difficulties with my
son sometimes i thought of you father i cannot fathom having
had more children to contend yeah but experienced it though
so um her mom never got to experience the melody now that
spent her entire life growing up in the forest yes well i
was not terribly successful at contending with you a lot now
was i it took little you look so much nicer now see him and
the others again soon after like being cured from i guess
being a sociopath not reach mount olympus it seems but zoos
does have my full report yeah ringing endorsement is his
lips bigger too if time can be so cruel then it is only
fitting for his children he's been like would you not agree
grand altar he's been like what's it called looks maxing he
looks like he's been looks maxing bro apparently if you i
was okay i'm sorry i'm this is like um i'm ruining the
immersion of the story yeah but apparently there's like this
trend of is it called looks maxing uh or muing or whatever
apparently there's like drugs and stuff that you take for it
and like there's this guy that's talking about how he's like
yeah bro i'm fucking committed to this looks maxing like and
then apparently it makes you like infertile
Yeah, to get like the perfect looks- looks maxing.
We may have more in common than we'd like to admit.
But in any event, Lord Uncle Zeus asked you to come alone.
Only the fates now know what lies in store.
Although there's still no sign of them, even with Nix's aid.
Yeah, we- I cast them into the abyss.
Had I known precisely where they would have known how to get
back, yet if my hypothesis at such possibilities oh they you
threw them in the abyss we may fight them oh jesus he just
throws them into the fucking pit we shall and i look forward
to testing this hypothesis perhaps we'll all learn something
about ourselves jesus would that we could gods and titans
yeah literally chucked them into the void but we need not be
bound to why old ways indeed um father thank you for all
your hospitality it gladdens me to see you doing well i
would not be if not for my god i trust that we should no
longer looks like he's homeless let's go perhaps even you
father likewise hiddies at least this house is mostly to
your preference again beyond these halls of course more is
to be done yes well father i wish you the best with the
ongoing underworld renovations as for us our chariot is here
let's shop thank you for the super chat that you think this
is such a wholesome family ending except for the mortals
we're still dead that it is i am prepared i don't think the
gods care about the mortals anyway They were literally mad
that they got fire.
Like, how fucking dare you give them fire?
Great mix.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, night and moon.
My third mom.
Mom remains secure in keeping watch above it all.
I never doubted that I could count on you.
But mother, had our watch been more dependable than none of
this would have transpired.
trying times shall always come about testing our resolve
thus we grow strong as do the bonds we share even now i
sense the powerful connection between you oh look there's
your voice of the underworld it was my honor to work with
sister selenia o'nix she has always been my guiding light
except for my last fucking run apparently he's like he's
always been my oh always literally my last run i didn't even
see her
that's crazy oh with his side eyes
thank you mother and farewell for now i must say i did not
expect that we could ever draw you down this far sister
selenie i thought perhaps not even had mr code in all her
experience.
Oh, hey, hey, Kati.
Oh, hey.
If you are ready, little star, then let us go, lest we
outstay our greetings and farewells.
I am honored to have seen these halls and to return to
shadow with you on this night in victory, not haste.
I will say this entire time, I am so confused with what her
head is.
Like, is that a helmet?
Or, like, hair.
I miss oh my god it's a helmet wait I see it now I I'm this
the head this is like the it's so confusing I thought it was
literally like hair for the longest time but like very ugly
hairstyle yeah I I can see it now I see it now I was just
like I I've noticed the blue blue I thought the blue thing
wave thingy was just aura yeah yeah i i just realized that
it wasn't aura it's like like the moon aura you know because
she you can finally see her fucking um sprite like the in
the background
yeah yeah i noticed it now i can i can see the hair now.
Come, Malinoi, for all the reasons that Salini says, we have
a delivery that we must make besides.
Then let's be off.
I think the helmet is definitely not very appealing, I will
say that.
I just always thought I was just like, I was like,
everything else looks beautiful, but I was like, bro, that
hair needs to go.
Then let us ride into the dark above.
And do be careful to hold on as we depart.
Farewell.
Bye.
Yeah, we're going to Olympus.
Yeah.
You get to fly like this each night.
If I may briefly interrupt, we have arrived at our initial
destination, everyone.
Olympus is not far from here.
I do appreciate the ride upon your gleaming chariot, O moon.
But it is time for me to go.
Perhaps my conversations with Hades have prepared me to face
my other sons.
We've informed Lord Uncle Zeus of what happened and given
our recommendations.
Though he'll have many questions for you.
And ought to be expecting you by now.
Remember the chance you've been given, Grandfather.
I'm not coming with you.
Time cannot forget.
And ought to never to be late.
at least permit me to assist you from here on knowing there
were real possibilities this all could have gone worse to
think that the entire flow of time has fractured because of
what occurred i would liken it more to a moment of
self-discovery on my part despite my advanced stage it seems
i did not know all that there is to know about myself but
then again who does now farewell wait and thank you grand
altar Wait, no.
Bring me with you to Olympus.
Hello?
Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, hello.
Thought we'd drop in.
Oh, hey.
Lord Apollo and Lady Artemis.
It's a beautiful night, Lady Selene.
And you must be the esteemed witch of the Crossroads.
You've trained my cousin very well indeed to have brought
Kronos to our heights, still in one piece.
Fine, Apollo.
I was incorrect for once.
No need to boast.
Malinui, I may have wagered that you'd cut the Titan to
ribbons sooner than you'd bring him here.
I know it's unimaginable, but he came here willingly.
And Lord Zeus wanted to speak to him in private.
Wait, does that mean you were kicked out of your house?
Huh?
Well, we consider it a palace, but, uh, no.
No, we've been appointed to escort you to the crossroads as
a symbol of our family's unity.
Okay.
We ride.
Here we go.
Yay.
We did it!
Guys, we fucking finally beat Hades!
Oh my god.
What a wild ride.
I mean, I would like to move to Olympus, but okay, or you
know live back home with my family, but Guess I'll be in the
I'm back in the forest now
Yeah, I finished the tutorial guys we finally did it
That was fun though, I've always loved I love roguelike so
much so Obviously, hey these two scratch that itch for me
Um, so it's a very fun experience.
Um, no, not now, but no, no, no, no, no, there is no there's
no true ending time.
I will say I think I think it's weird that I'm still in the
forest.
I feel like he needs one or two more.
There's like Okay, in Hades 1, I had less things to complain
about.
But in Hades 2, like, they've added so much more to Hades 1,
expanded a lot upon it.
But I really, really did not like the Ares Edition.
Fuck that shit.
Yeah, I think I will say I like Hades 1's story more.
I would like that and I hate Fighting Typhon seven times
Because like Kronos I get it because Kronos is a lot easier
Like the The the hell The underworld levels are so easy That
like the Kronos level I don't mind grinding that shit But
The typhoon ship?
No, fuck that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was not a huge fan.
Because, like, the thing is, for Kronos, this is the
underground, for the underworld, like, all the bosses, like,
when you get a hang of it, all the bosses are pretty easy.
It's just Kronos at the end.
But for the surface one, it's, it's, like, all the, like,
it's, like, Ares, Prometheus.
theus and Typhon like back to back to back as like it's
frustrating as hell
yeah just to get the first ending I feel like for the first
ending it should be like a little easier
I as wish like the first ending was not like that much
grinding for the surface level I won't say, okay, easier is
not the right word.
Just, it was, just too much, too much fucking runs for the
surface level.
I just, I just don't like, I just didn't like that to fight
Typhon six times.
It's just Typhon.
It's Typhon, Aeris, and Prometheus back to back.
Fuck those guys.
And this fucking eagle.
Oh, I don't think I didn't forget about the goddamn eagle.
Fuck that bird.
God!
Yeah, no, that eagle was goddamn annoying.
The gameplay was fun, though.
The gameplay was really fun.
Also, fuck Zeus for, like, just throwing a thunderbolt and
be like, I did all we could.
Because at least, like, in the...
story of one it made like it made more sense but then in two
i'm like why why the fuck aren't you guys helping we're
literally at olympus like like i don't need to borrow your
powers you can use your powers right now we're outside your
house we're like that's why i'm like that's where i was a
little confused because i was like bro we're literally
outside your house like can't you like help out more he just
throws one thunderbug like i did all i could i was like i
see hera inside olympus what the is she doing the spirit
ruler of the dead restored to his rightful throne alongside
splendorous persevere and then after i killed him they're
like you're chilling upon olympus finally ceased and ever
since the gods governed our world with newfound care
princess of the dead millenoi she stayed in steady touch
with all her family from the dark yeah shadows that had long
since been her home oh i like how the eyes is like different
for them sisters kept their secret vigil over all the realms
forevermore may it all turn out that way in time homer they
were not there oh it's homie that voice did we achieve
something important I forgot about that.
Yay!
I said we're not finished.
Oh, do I no longer brood?
I'm happy now.
I don't think I forgot about you, little one.
I didn't even bring my frog back home.
I left him in the forest.
Hello, I did my job.
Hey, so what exactly happened around here?
Chop, chop done.
Chop done.
Because that's what I'm hearing.
from the other shades joki hates eagles that's what's
happening she hates america it's a broken pot thank you the
super chat thank you that eagle isn't even american my
brother's back too but we have many details to sort out and
he doesn't even live in america
the titan you said you were going to slay this whole time
assisting us hate to say it mel but sounds to me yeah that
was neat that they had home we're narrating all of this
because he is like the uh uh the writer he's no longer
himself or rather no longer the way he used to be and we'll
be closely watching him sure so then congratulations are in
order basically well if you like what i do i don't think
america was discovered yet back then guys i have a feeling
So what do I...
So how is he still fighting?
I'm a little confused.
How is he still fighting if...
Alright, I guess I'll collect your trash again.
I guess...
It's your local trash collector.
The Krono stuff I'm hearing?
He's really calling it quits?
And he let Nixon everybody off?
What did you do to him?
Wait, why do I...
fight chronos then in the underworld oh alternate versions
of them oh
my concern is that you ruined everything so now we'll all
have peace and harmony joy yeah apologies promises to never
let this type of thing happen again have you met our
families aris it's never that simple it better not be or
i'll never forgive you you.
Your task is finally complete.
I did it, yeah.
Perhaps the fates knew you'd succeed.
But I couldn't always be certain.
Although I held to what could be considered hope.
And your support made it possible, Lord Moros.
For one thing, if you hadn't intervened when I was trying to
reach the surface, Typhon might have reduced Olympus to
ruin.
Next, see, thank you, thank you, thank you.
So true.
She's angry.
That makes me happy.
The feud continues.
We'll never have a truce.
Oh,
hey.
I can make more stuff.
I don't really need any of these things to be found.
bear all hail the princess of the oh my gosh still it's
still growing that into the not expected to still be growing
it's like in the other story it's just nothing else i mean
okay i might as well
see that sisters how are you faring lately head mistress
you've been well more reserved than i the house of Hades you
said we'd speak more later how soon later turns to now look
Melinaway I ought to be in a more celebratory mood given
what you finally achieved I am above all very proud of yay
being back at the house awakened memories that ought to
remain dormant even though you got to see mother and father
again and Nix they were so grateful to you I could tell I am
so grateful to you Things may not have gone precisely as we
planned, but the result is what we sought, isn't it?
Yeah.
I mean, her result was deaf to Kronos.
You refer to Kronos.
Yeah, yeah, see?
She's like, um, I wanted her to be dead.
I am attempting still to draw back to the hand.
I get you ahead, close enough.
I remember you once told me that destroying Kronos would not
change the past and that the pain would linger And I was
probably correct yet we cannot help but reassess the turns
our lives take Through our own choices and otherwise Anyhow
are you prepared to carry on?
Yeah Nearly so retracing my steps should be interesting
all right who else wants to talk to me all right nemesis got
your mom back welcome after the titan got her eye ought to
have taken guard duty more seriously and won't soon forgive
myself as all headmistress would only want for you to learn
from it i half wonder if she let herself be taken just to
get closer to our mark perhaps go speak with her yeah and
what of chronos heard he isn't but he's cheering for you
then he's dead and gone in the sense that we have
neutralized the threat he posed I now shall have to grow
accustomed to having him as a grandfather rather than a
hated foe oh is that girl thank you listen richard thank you
thank you didn't get game of the year because there was
enough moments where our favorite the Lulu queen's yellow
don't see why he can't be both this was never part of the
task and not like you to stray from the I think they didn't
get game in the year because there's no Perry they couldn't
headmistress sealed his strongest powers just in case at any
rate we did it them then how come you look like you're
headed out again or there's still more time related business
to sort out well yes but what not done you found a path to
victory and got us there wouldn't have been much of a plan
and lack of French improvise of course our plan now also has
this other phase as a result
cleaning up after cronos we all thought i would get rid of
him but i found another way what one i think shall leave my
family better off if not the rest of the world eventually oh
yeah yeah yeah i well i thought he was talking they were
talking about like a different cronos your choice was wise
oh yeah no i get it what's next everything is ready for you
to proceed if and when you are eliminating real
possibilities that we could have failed oh there you go here
you go as Kronos puts it I don't quite know what to expect
but the change we're fighting that's like unlimited though
what do you make of it you can never there's unlimited
possibilities we can never get rid of it to try to the
extent you had other matters to resolve to do so and we'll
always be anticipating your return then let's give it a go
is he awake yet all right my memories of you from that
potential past i experienced in the house of hades you were
so different lord hypnos who are you truly how can i finally
get through to you will he ever wake up is he like in the
coma forever all right time to put grandfather's theories to
the test the only question is where to begin the group with
Kronos both above and okay we are not doing that we what do
you mean regroup with Kronos both up no no this is it's only
you're We'll talk to him one last time.
I want you to stroke my ego one last time.
Thank you very much, Commander.
Though, what are you still doing here?
I kept expecting you to return to your honorary post at the
house.
but eventually I had to depart.
Well, you are not exactly done with everything, are you?
I see your eyeball and the gateways out, wondering what's
gonna happen now.
So as long as you are here, show them I.
So then you're sworn to us, to me.
Yeah, I'm not going anywhere.
Yay!
All right, I'm gonna call it here, guys.
We did it!
We finally beat Hades!
So!
The first game we finished for 20, 26 everyone yeah we were
here we were here thank you everyone for watching guys that
was fun i love roguelike so there's always a fun time um fun
time to play more roguelike um i hope you guys had a lot of
fun watching too uh it's been a long journey with haiti's a
lot of times where i thought the game guys and then there's
like but wait there's more dokey there's a surface level i'm
like what and i'm like guys i did that beat typhoon but wait
dokey there's more you have to beat him six more times i'm
like what and i'm like i did it guys i beat typhoon but wait
dokey there's more yeah go back and fight chronos i'm like
oh
But it's just done.
We got we got an ending That's that's all I wanted.
We did it guys.
We we got an ending.
We were here for it But thank you guys.
Happy new year.
Happy 2026 guys what a great way to start 2026 beating our
first game of the year I hope you guys all head to bed it's
really late late guys everybody i want to say um relate to
the um to vr chat world to doky land i want to say thank you
again for supporting the stream and the team and this
channel and me um like i said i couldn't have done it
without all of your support guys you guys helped made this
happen like i can stream because of you guys um if you guys
guys supporting me and i always like to reinvest into the
channel too so um and in the community because like i said
below well you guys i wouldn't be able to make this a career
so thank you everyone and i hope you guys have a wonderful
night thank you for being a dragon happy new year dragons
let's make this a crazy year for 2026 as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around and get
that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.